Four,
three,
two,
boom.
What's up man?
How are Ya?
Hello.
Thanks for being here.
Well,
I'm pleased to get here.
It's a kind of a strange day in this
part of strangers that every gets there.
The big concern in Los Angeles has
always been according to a firefighter
that I've talked to.
Once that the right wind catches a fire
and it takes it all the way through Los
Angeles,
down to the coast.
Well,
it's not quite that.
It didn't go through Hollywood.
It didn't go.
They think one day it's going to happen
and with the right when they're not
gonna be able to stop it,
but she's just.
Yeah,
this was pretty bad.
This is about as bad as I've ever seen
in happen all in one day.
Yeah.
It was extraordinary.
Driving down the road to get here.
Just these huge,
just huge pillowy.
The.
I thought it was just,
you know,
mountains and I thought it was a strange
cloud formation,
but it was just smoke smoke.
Yeah.
It looks like a giant gray mountain in
the distance.
Yeah,
it's,
it's insane how bad it's gotten.
I've,
I've had it happen three,
this is the third time I've been
evacuated since I've moved here 20 plus
years ago.
Wow.
Yeah,
it gets her off.
But this is the roughest have ever seen.
Jamie and I were doing the podcast
yesterday and when it was over,
I had like five text messages from
friends that live in my neighborhood
saying how bad it was.
And then when we got home the wind was
just crazy and it was just,
it's just,
it's humbling,
you know,
I mean,
it's super unfortunate for all the
people that are losing their homes and
losing.
They're losing their property.
But the reality is this is um,
it's nature.
This is just something that you just
can't avoid it.
There's nothing you can do about it.
It gets dry like this and I don't know
what started it.
I hope it wasn't a cigarette because
that's the big concisely so many moron.
So throwing cigarettes.
It's not just a weather thing that just
happens.
It's,
it is literally things like cigarettes
and unfortunately a lot of the times it
means the weather certainly accentuates
it because it's dry and windy.
And this is fire season.
Well
anyway.
Hey,
thanks for being here man.
He's incredibly comfortable.
Chairs.
They're not bad.
Right?
They're amazing because they support
your back as well,
which is a 47 year old man is helpful.
So I'll keep bouncing away from the
microphone,
which I'm sure isn't good.
But yeah,
they're incredible.
They keep you sitting straight to
accentuate your posture.
They do.
There you go.
So what's up man?
What are you doing in town?
Shoulders,
back,
chest out.
They would be proud.
There you go.
I'm here.
Yeah,
I'm here doing a idea for a week.
I've been A.
I've got a show on Netflix that's come
out,
so I'm just kind of generally here to
talk about it I guess.
And uh,
seeing a couple of friends and it's been
a really nice,
really nice week.
Yeah,
this is a good way to end it too with a
giant fire and just saying get the fuck
out of here quickly.
These people are crazy living here with
no water.
Never rains.
Yeah,
it'll be.
It's very different.
Back home.
It'll be.
It'll.
Yeah.
It's uh,
it's,
it's amazing.
Just at this time of year,
leaving England and coming to somewhere
like,
I mean,
I'm sure,
I'm sure you don't take it for granted,
but you know,
it's,
it is amazing.
Just for the weather and just for a bit
you,
would you like la as a,
like as a place in our home and uh,
does it,
I mean,
you've got an amazing sort of set up
there.
Is it just a,
is it just a dream place to you?
It's a,
it's a love hate relationship.
Certainly the,
the real problem is the population is
just so insane.
There's more than 20 million people.
Plus who knows people,
you know,
how many.
They really don't have no idea how many
people have snuck in.
You know,
it's,
it's just a chaotic place.
There's no public transport.
It just hit me that.
No,
there's no trains,
there's no infrastructure.
A,
everyone's driving these huge.
Everyone has an escalator or a tesla or
something.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's just a strange place.
There's,
the highways are massive.
You know,
you have five,
six lanes on each side and they're
jammed solid where nothing's moving
either way.
And if you can see it from there,
really we realized how preposterous it
is when you're flying into lax and you
see the four,
oh,
five highway and the distance and it's
all stopped for as long as you could see
miles one way miles the other way.
Just complete parking lot and just
realize,
wow,
what are we doing here?
Found a spot with great weather and you
know,
and then the entertainment industry
draws people in.
I don't know,
maybe it's better to be in England to
keep the rain a little bit,
a little bit.
She had like a little bit that I like,
I do like a bit of the Ela,
so anyway,
I'll take a lot of pictures and it's
very nice like when the rain clears and
everything's sort of glistens and that's
a nice.
Yeah.
Your instagram is interesting,
you know,
it's surprising.
Well yeah,
I mainly put,
I paint and I do a lot of street
photography.
So those,
those.
I've already got into instagram recently
and I've just been putting,
putting that stuff on there,
which I don't know how interesting it
is.
Generally a nice place to put that kind
of stuff.
I paint like these big portraits and
they just ended up sitting around my
house.
No one wants to buy it.
No one's to buy a giant picture of my
mother,
so they don't really sell them,
so they just sit around.
So actually,
yeah,
putting them on.
At least that's not my mother.
Just for clarity is your stuff is really
good.
Thank you.
Are these.
It's a caricature is Tom waits once.
Excellent.
It's surprisingly good.
I mean you think someone is really good
at something like magic and you say,
well that's about as good as he's
getting.
Get it.
It's not like he's going to be that good
at something else,
but you are literally flicking through
my instagram.
Yeah,
I mean you're,
you're really good art artist.
Thank you very much.
Have you done this your whole life?
Not yet.
Um,
yeah.
Pretty much like as a,
as a kid I used to draw and paint a lot
and always faces like I'm no good else,
but a faces has always been my thing,
so I should do like cut these kind of,
you know,
characatures and now I paint more,
sort of straight pictures I guess.
But it's nice if you do something that's
kind of,
you know,
public,
it's nice to do something that's private
and it's that thing of something bigger
than yourself to throw yourself into and
dilute yourself in and it's great,
you know,
days,
weeks of,
you know,
just being in my studio is just as
lovely.
That's a great thing.
Do you find that stuff like that clears
your mind for your other work?
I think it's,
it's just the sheer contrast,
you know,
and one of my favorite parts of the year
is touring and I get to do the shows in
the evening and then the days are free
and I'm like,
I'm not in London,
I'm in some other cities,
so no one can.
No one can like get me in for a meeting
or anything.
I just had the days free and I can
write.
I had a book on happiness that I wrote,
which I wrote while I was on tour and it
was just this amazing routine of just
finding a coffee shop,
spending the day writing,
and then if that does get a bit,
you know,
a bit boring or a bit sad or something.
If it's not quite coming together,
you've Dang you then get to go out and
be this amazingly charismatic,
well rehearsed version of yourself on
stage,
which is,
you know,
full of adrenaline and lovely.
So that,
that's an amazing routine.
I think that's my favorite,
favorite thing.
So yeah,
the painting and all that.
Photography is an interesting one
because you,
you,
you find yourself on the one hand kind
of slightly because I do street
photography so it's kind of,
you know,
out taking pictures of candid moments I
guess.
So your,
you're a step out of it,
but you're also very open and engaged
and,
and that feels like a really prime state
that's very kind of porous,
lovely state to be in and having been
used to keeping my head down out in
public because I realize I'm not known
here at all.
But in the UK I a bit.
So if I,
if I was out in public or generally kind
of naturally kind of hunker,
hunker down and now it's the opposite.
It's totally changed that relationship.
So that's good.
Yeah.
It's not just photography,
just being out there and taking pictures
of you having to be mindful and open and
alert and uh,
but at the same time,
because I'm probably a little bit shy.
So having that little step back thing as
well because you're,
you know,
taking pictures is,
is uh,
I found that really,
really great state and it's a lovely
contrast to the,
uh,
the shows and the,
you know,
the rest of it
or you always shy or did you become more
shy because of becoming really famous?
I was always,
well,
not always.
I think I grew quite,
um,
that's probably quite insecure to get.
It was very charming and very,
um,
uh,
quite bright and quite like socially,
you know,
that was,
that was all good.
But I think like inside I was,
um,
I was very intimidated by the kind of
sporty kids you would have terrified me
as a,
as a child.
Um,
and uh,
I fled,
uh,
kids like kids,
just sports,
just not use that because I really
didn't fit in with any of that.
Um,
and so when I first started,
I started my career as a hypnotist and
I,
I saw this guy performing at university
and I,
uh,
I just thought I'm going to,
I'm going to do that.
It just,
I,
I didn't realize at the time all these
boxes that it was,
you know,
performing that sort of,
need for affirmation and love and center
of attention and also the control aspect
of it,
you know,
the kind of um,
uh,
yeah,
the control aspect and also the kind of
people that,
particularly the sort of guys that would
respond well to hypnosis and come up on
stage and you know,
and respond well to it,
tell it to be exactly the kind of guys
that would really intimidated me before.
So that was at an unconscious level and
I hope I've grown out of that now.
Main Labor.
Yeah.
It takes a lot of,
it takes a lot of boxes.
So that was,
that's how I started in the Em's.
Definitely driven by insecurity because
Eddie's any sort of magic which sort of
followed me on from the hypnosis,
you're basically,
it is the quickest,
most fraudulent route of impressing
people.
That's the subtext is only look at my
great,
which is not that interesting after
afterwards.
So I've tried to,
you know,
as I've,
as I've grown up,
I've tried to move into a different area
and one that's a little more resonant
than just showing off.
That's fascinating that you started out
doing hypnosis,
shows that a comedy show,
I know it was sort of,
um,
I would mainly performance like uh,
colleges and I do a demonstration and
then have questions and questions and
answers afterwards and I wasn't making
people look stupid.
It was an entertainment show and I guess
it was kind of funny,
but it was um,
it was,
uh,
it's just a really interesting thing and
the trouble with doing on stage is
because it gets mixed up with people
just kind of playing along and stuff.
So it,
it's.
But if you take that out of it,
it's just a really interesting area and
I've done this stuff for,
you know,
20 years back home and I'm not,
I don't think of myself as a hypnotist.
That was just kind of where I,
where I started.
But the suggestion based techniques.
So that is something I continued with
and brought into different areas and I
still don't fully understand it.
You know,
now you can have a quiet climates inside
someone's head and know what they're
experiencing.
Like I used to do in the,
what I used to do these like stage
hypnosis shows.
The last thing I did was to,
I'd tell these people on stage that I
was invisible,
right.
And I'd,
I'd float something through the air,
right.
Like this bottle I've got here is,
it's normally something bigger like a
chair and they'd be freaking out,
running off stage and so on.
But afterwards,
when I'd had this kind of q and a I
them,
I'd ask them,
what was your,
what was your actual experience like,
like,
the show's over and I'll be honest,
what we,
what you're experiencing.
And you'd get some people that would
say,
well yeah,
you were obviously just floating that
you were just holding it,
but I kind of felt like I had to play
along and then you'd get this
interesting area in the middle of,
of like,
well I kind of,
I now when I think that yes,
of course it was you,
but it was and I sort of knew it was
you,
but I am emotionally just completely.
I could only experience it as a
terrifying floating bottle or whatever
it was.
So that's a bit like an actor,
like getting caught up in a role I
guess.
Like they know,
they know they're onstage and it's a
character,
but nonetheless emotionally committed.
And at the other extreme,
people that would not accept that it was
me floating,
it just,
they that must have been on a wire or
something.
There's no,
there's no way that I could drop you
back at the picture in my memory of that
thing.
So how do you know?
How do you,
how do you judge what that experience is
when there's and,
and all those people that are saying,
no,
you are really invisible.
Are they just saying that because they
want to be like the best subjects in
that,
in that group.
I mean,
how do you tease it all apart?
It's that is,
is that that must be a real issue,
right?
The people that just want to please you
and are playing along.
How can you tell if you were fighting
people?
Yeah,
I can tell,
but I.
The way I use it now,
he's kind of,
I use it quite sort of subtly in the
show.
I don't like overtly hypnotize people,
so that means it can mean one of two
things.
It either means it just,
I'm not interested people playing along
because I'm not just trying to create
the effect of someone hypnotized.
They need to genuinely be responding to
this thing in order for the next bit to
work,
in which case I have to filter out
anybody playing lumbered,
but occasionally,
occasionally it doesn't matter.
Like a lot of the time,
like I'll get people up on stage and
I'll shake their hand and they're,
there's a rapid handshake induction that
the guidance just falls to the floor.
Um,
and there are times that that matters
and they have to be,
that has to be really honest response.
Other times I can tell they're sort of
half into it and they're just a bit
intimidated and,
but for the 2000 people looking,
that might look,
it kind of might look like the same
thing and then it won't,
does exactly.
Does that work?
The handshake induction,
what?
It's,
it's a,
uh,
I take no responsibility for explaining
this to your tens of millions of
listeners and viewers.
Um,
but,
uh,
it's,
you're,
you're interrupting a,
an automatic process,
right?
This is the,
this is the key to it was made popular
by,
um,
made popular by I guess Richard Bandler
who's the guy behind nlp and so on.
I don't know if he kind of created this
thing,
but perhaps perhaps Erickson did before
him.
I don't know.
Anyway,
you take an automatic process and you
interrupted in the middle.
So like when you're shaking hands with
somebody,
it's such a familiar process that when
you start,
you're not thinking,
okay,
I'm going to grip this person's hand
now.
Now I'm going to move my hand up and
down with them a few times.
Then I'll take my hand to what you just
kind of do it automatically.
And there's something about interrupting
that that Leaves People Really
flummoxed and bewildered because they're
really,
really caught off guard.
Like if you imagine somebody comes up to
you in the street and says it's not half
past seven,
you know,
your reaction isn't to go,
yeah,
I know it's 20 past nine.
Your reaction is,
is a sort of,
you think you've missed something,
like you're trying to make sense of it.
It's a strange,
uh,
Kinda put you on the back foot.
And at that point if you to,
if you've got somebody who's fairly
suggestible and people coming up on
stage,
it's such an odd moment for them anyway.
They're naturally wrote,
suggestible that a clear instruction to
sleep or whatever you want give them,
tends to be taken very deeply and very
often than you'll see on shake hands.
And I'll,
I'll break the pattern of the
handshakes.
I'll,
I'll often take their hand and lifted up
to their face and say sleep and show
them their hand like that and they just
sleep and well it's not sleep that it's
a kind of um,
it looks like.
I mean they,
they'll do anything from eyes closed.
Head drops down to just drop like a,
like a dead weight on the floor,
you know,
what I found is most interesting
actually.
It was like applying this in slightly
more useful everyday situations was as a
sort of like a self defense technique.
I was walking a between so I was like,
must have been like 20 or something and
I was at a magic convention and I was
walking from one hotel to another and
I'm dressing like a three piece velvet
suit as skinny British law,
but might as well have,
you know,
punched me in the throat,
tattooed across my face.
And this guy comes up and it's like he's
drunk and he's about three in the
morning.
Drunk aggressive is with his girlfriend,
clearly looking for a fight.
And uh,
he sort of,
he comes up to me and he says,
well,
what do you,
what do you fucking looking at when
you're looking at?
And because I'd spoken about this,
how to deal with this sort of thing,
but it never found myself in this
situation.
I kind of had it all mentally rehearsed.
So I said to him,
I said,
the wall outside,
my house isn't four foot high and I
guess there's an equivalent to this with
sort of adrenaline dump.
I think it's called and in martial arts,
but there's a,
it just like,
he's got all this adrenaline and then a
thing like that for me,
which is just out of context.
Like it makes sense.
I'm not talking gibberish.
It makes sense,
but it's just out of context.
So now suddenly he's thinking,
I've what?
I've missed something.
So now he,
he was sort of went what?
And I said his girlfriend walked off and
I said,
the wall outside,
my house isn't for,
for high.
I spent some time in Spain,
the walls that were very high,
but if you look at the ones here that
they're tiny,
they're nothing.
And then he just sort of broke down.
He sort of at war,
ha.
And uh,
started crying,
what,
you know,
it wasn't quite crying,
but it was just,
it was like all the adrenaline and
everything just just flooded out of him.
And he sat down and I ended up sitting
next to him on the,
uh,
on the road side.
I'm asking him,
you know,
so what was the plan was I was going to
try and stick his feet to the floor and
lay out.
His whole family just kind of collapsed
and sat down.
So yeah,
that was because I knew it would be like
this highly suggestible state and either
way,
the moment of aggression and passed.
But I ended up,
ended up weirdly sitting with them,
asking him what had happened that
evening and his girlfriend,
I think she'd bottled somebody or
something horrible had happened.
So we'd got out with all this
aggression,
but it's a,
it's a good one,
isn't it?
If you just have like,
um,
it could be just a song lyric or just
some,
some weird kind of thing that you can
just go into in those situations.
I mean,
if someone's running at you with a
knife,
it's a bit difficult,
but you just,
you,
you're kind of strangely taking control
of a situation.
Otherwise what you're going to do if
they say,
what are you looking at?
You can't,
there's no way you can answer that
without being on the back foot.
So it just kind of nicely kind of
inverts the situation and puts them on
the bank vault,
which anyway,
it worked.
It was a,
it was kind of fun.
Isn't there like a process required to
hypnotize someone?
You could just do it that way and saying
it didn't.
Just talk them through some sort of a
program that makes them think their foot
is stuck to the floor.
I,
it,
it will.
Depends on the moment I had.
I used to hypnotize people in my,
in my room when I was a student.
Right.
So I was the guy that did hypnosis,
what are people coming regularly coming
to to try it out?
And um,
I this,
this one time I used to leave people
with like if they were responsive to it
and this was like I was really early
days,
it was like 20 minutes,
half an hour of relaxing somebody and
maybe suggesting that their hands were
getting lightened floating or heavy and
they couldn't lift them.
So kind of,
you know,
kind of basic stuff.
But I would leave them if they were very
suggestible with the instruction that
when you come back,
if I click my fingers,
you'll get back into the sleep state and
they,
you know,
they kind of get conditioned to that.
It'll often work even like a week later
and this guy came and uh,
I thought I'd seen him before.
I thought he'd been on the previous
week.
So he sat down and I go look at me and
sleep,
click my fingers.
And he went out,
whatever that means.
Right?
And then we did whatever it was.
Maybe perhaps you wanted to stop smoking
or his hands floating in the air.
Whatever it wasn't at the end of it,
I realized in talking to him that I
hadn't met him before,
so then I'm like,
well,
how did,
why did you respond to me clicking my
fingers because I don't have magic
fingers.
There's nothing like anything going on
here other than.
And I realized it was just that.
It was just that moment of my kind of
confidence with it and the fact
fortuitously that he was also very
suggestible and put those two things
together.
That's what made it work.
It was just that,
that psychological moment for him that
was more important than the nature of
the 20 minute script that I'd been
learning and using up to that point.
So that was kind of a seminal seminal.
Yes.
Confidence in that he had already been
under.
Yeah.
I didn't question it because I really,
I believe that he had and it just kind
of,
it just sort of happened and then he
just.
If he hadn't been a suggestible type and
it probably wouldn't have worked,
but luckily he was.
And that kind of really,
really changed the way that I,
that I thought about hypnosis and also
started this,
you know,
this realization that ultimately my,
my kind of toolkit with what I do is,
is the stories that people are telling
themselves that's,
that's kind of,
that's really all there is.
Even a magician showing you a card trick
is just getting you to tell yourself a
story,
edit,
edit this event in such a way that you
go,
oh,
you know,
I picked a card and then it disappeared
and it was,
it was in my pocket.
He never went near me.
And you it out.
All the bits that don't seem important.
Like when he complimented you on your
jacket earlier on in the day and may
have stuck a card in there or the bit
where he took the car back for a moment,
whatever.
Because you don't,
you know,
you're,
you're being sold a story with a
particular sort of edit points.
And you know,
to me that's interesting because that's
what life is,
you know,
we have this infinite data source coming
at us.
We can,
we just have to kind of reduce it to
store is to make to make sense.
I think stripping aside all the kind of
Vaudeville and tacky associations of
hypnotists and magicians and solid think
there's something.
There's something interesting at the
heart of it.
I think that that our storytelling
capacity is endlessly fascinating to me.
Well,
it's fascinating in that regard,
but it's also fascinating that there
seems to be like some cheat code,
the human mind,
like there's a,
there's a way you can like lock into
like an admin panel and all of a sudden
you're doing things like telling people
they don't really don't want to be
smoking or putting them into this
hypnotic mindset by just snapping your
fingers and sang sleep.
It's odd.
I think it is.
I think it looks like that and that's
the problem because it looks it.
It's.
You so often see it when performers are
doing it and they're often going for
kind of theatrical effect.
If you go and look at it like a clinical
environment where hypnosis are being
investigated,
it isn't like that at all.
It's much more a kind of boring in a
wiser,
isn't,
it?
Doesn't have any theater attached to it
as much more on,
you know,
kind of intuitively understandable had
been hypnotized yourself.
I'm terrible.
I'm a really bad,
really bad subject.
I had one experience where I only one
when I was in like a workshop thing that
I was,
there is a,
like a,
you know,
a pain,
a person that wasn't giving the workshop
and um,
I was sat with,
uh,
the,
the exercise was,
it really worked for me.
It might work for others.
So you're split into pairs and uh,
the idea is you start to describe a
scene.
So you sat,
sat with this woman,
you close your eyes,
you start to describe a scene and you
get back and forth adding details.
Right?
So she says I become laying on a beach.
And um,
so I just imagine that like,
okay,
now I'm going to beach and I can,
um,
I can feel the warmth of the sun on my
face.
So I'm just kind of like imagining it
and joining in with the story.
And then I just remember somebody going,
okay,
guys,
time out,
time for lunch.
And I,
I,
I had been on a behind beat on a beach
and I,
I'd completely just,
I'd been there like a dream.
It was completely real at some point it
tipped into that.
That's the only experience I've had of
it.
Other than that,
I don't respond to it.
I'm just not.
I think it's just suggestibility.
It's something about a.
and we get it when you know,
we get it,
when a doctor gives us a placebo and we
respond to that because this authority
figure is giving us that or,
or the way we absorb a opinions of
people that we admire and experts that
we admire.
How we just more easily take those on
board.
Unquestioningly this is all the same
thing.
It's just suggestion.
The trouble is most of the time it's
done through the world of the performing
hypnotists,
which isn't.
It isn't giving really a very clear and
fair view of what was going on because
it's so theatrical and so often you
know,
you're,
you're relishing and things like I click
my fingers and this guy went to sleep,
but that's not really,
you know,
the,
what are they doing?
Their Qa,
they just,
I think just kind of responding because
you've just asked them to and they know
that when you click their fingers,
they're supposed to go to sleep is
there's a real range of possible
experiences that you might look like a
power,
but it doesn't mean it is.
They might just be just complying.
I was going to do some of this stuff on
stage without using the hypnosis to show
that there's.
I don't think there's anything that
happens under Moses that can't be done
without a.
and I was having this discussion with my
friend Andy who directs and my stage
shows with me and I was saying like that
thing of,
you know,
when you,
when a hypnotist get somewhere to eat an
onion and says,
you know,
this is a classic hypnotic stone.
Gives them a raw onion and says it's a
delicious juicy apple.
Now we sit and enjoy it and you get
somebody munching into an onion and like
having no problem eating it.
I was like,
well,
I'm sure that feels like if you're just
going to pull it off without hypnosis,
would that just happened anyway?
And Andy said,
I bet I bet you can use it anyway.
And he went to my fridge,
took out an onion,
took a big bite of it,
and it was fine because he's so.
He's proving a point there,
right?
So he's in a different mental state than
somebody going got a day to take a bite
of that onion when suddenly you're like,
you're preempting the,
you know,
the disgust and all the reasons not to
do it,
but the fact that he was just going,
I bet you can do it.
And trying to prove a point.
Many,
he did it and it was fine.
So that was a different mental state and
it worked.
So that wasn't hypnosis,
but the end result still,
if you do that onstage and pretended to
hypnotize somebody first it would look
like you've done something amazing.
So I don't know.
It is.
It's,
it's to me it's just,
it's just that story that someone's
telling themselves.
What did it taste like?
An onion to him or did it?
It just,
it's just,
it would have.
No,
no,
no.
It would have tasted like an onion.
I.
There was no suggestion of female that
are hypnotized.
Does it tastes like an apple to them?
Well,
I don't know.
It's like a monument.
Invisible one of the.
What are they seeing?
I think for some of them it will,
you know,
taste and pain and things like that and
discomfort.
It's all very subjective.
But the end result of doing this thing
that looks like it couldn't happen
without some magical process.
That's the key.
And none of these things really demand
that met.
Even when even when you look at people
being I'm undergoing surgery through
hypnosis and being wide awake and being
cut open.
So you think,
well that must be evidence.
The hypnosis is some special thing
because that couldn't happen otherwise,
but of course it can,
you know,
the layer of skin that feels pain is
actually sort of quite thin.
So once you get through that,
when you're moving organs around,
that's not,
that's not a painful process anyway.
Plus very fully tend to use a bit,
a little bit of like a local anesthetic
anyway just to numb the very top layer
of skin.
So again,
what looks amazing very often isn't,
it's a,
it's an endlessly rich and bizarre area
to me.
And I kind of,
um,
as I said,
I don't really think of myself as a
participant that the,
that process,
that kind of,
uh,
ability for people to get into this
space where they could have that kind of
experience is,
um,
is something I,
you know,
I'll always find interesting.
One of the recent stage shows I did a,
it's called miracle.
I don't know if you've seen it,
but I'm faith healing in the second
half.
So using exactly the same idea.
And I've got an audience that are like
me,
you know,
that don't believe in that.
And I'm saying,
look,
I mean I'm an atheist,
I don't believe in this either,
but will you just kind of go with me or
at least at the start,
because the results are a really
interesting.
And I,
um,
I just started doing this,
this,
I'm fighting,
not really knowing if it was going to
work.
I thought,
well,
I can get some adrenaline going and I
know could see the techniques that the
charlatan faith healers we're using.
And uh,
I thought,
well,
I'll just,
I'll,
I'll do that.
And I thought,
well,
the adrenaline kills pains,
I think get some adrenaline going.
There's bound to be people that said,
oh,
I had a pain in my back and now it's
gone.
But the actual results,
admittedly with small percentages of the
audience,
right,
not everybody,
but the people that were coming up and
saying,
I had this problem and now it's gone.
And they were,
there was a woman that had a,
she'd been paralyzed on one side of her
body since a kid.
And she's like,
in her forties now she's in floods of
tears going,
I couldn't move my arm.
And this was,
this is a skeptical audience like me
that know that there's kind of playing
along with something.
And uh,
nonetheless,
again,
small percentage,
not,
not everybody,
but having,
having these kinds of experiences.
It is.
So that's less of a psychological
component of suffering,
which,
which is,
which was really eye doing that show
night after night after night.
Well,
faith healing has got to be a form of
hypnosis,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
It's the same world is playing.
They both were,
they both joined by is the idea of
suggestibility and uh,
it doesn't.
And sometimes those healings,
it's sort of,
I mean,
if you take an x ray before and
afterwards,
nothing's changing,
but in as much as a lot can depend on
this psychological component,
it can,
can really make a difference.
It gives the percentages are getting
smaller.
So 3000 people in the audience,
300 people come up,
10 people come up on stage and I'm
involving them in the show,
but getting even smaller.
There are people that like a year later
we're getting in touch and say,
just so you know,
that thing did actually clear,
like it hasn't come back because I
thought it would only last for 10
minutes while they're on stage and then,
which is why you don't tell people to
throw the pills away and so on.
Right?
But we're in probably like that half a
percent now,
which is always going to be kind of
pretty extraordinary.
But um,
uh,
it was like a real,
real thing.
So when it's still,
if you had 200 people and one of them
actually cured from that,
that is immensely bizarre.
It's immensely bizarre,
but it's,
it's bizarre.
And,
and I'm like,
I had this bad shoulder for a long time
and I,
uh,
I got really used to,
when I put a jacket on,
kind of putting this in my left arm,
putting it in,
like letting my left arm go dead and
then using my right arm to pull the
thing up.
Right now I don't know how much I really
need to do that anymore or whether I'm
just doing it out of habit.
But if somebody got me up on stage and
said,
your left shoulder is healed,
it's now and kind of made me feel a bit
now go on,
try it,
try and move your,
move your arm.
I think in the surprise of it and the
sheer kind of just snapping out of that
habit of being like,
this is my dead arm,
I probably would be very surprised that
I could actually move it as much as I
can.
You know,
it's,
it's just,
it's like when you break it down,
it's like not that amazing.
But when you,
when you,
when you see the,
the,
the more kind of extreme and exciting
ends at that.
It's,
it is mind blowing.
And then you've realized how these
performance,
how you start to go mad yourself and
think,
well,
I've got this special gift I could pack
out stadia doing like,
uh,
I did think of one point,
why don't I do like a secular healing
show?
I could say,
well,
this is,
it's just,
you know,
it doesn't work in everybody and it may
only work for 10 minutes,
but it certainly works in some meaning
of the word anyway.
I didn't do that,
but you know,
you can start to go mad.
Well,
the processes of the mind,
I mean the idea of the placebo effect is
fascinating.
The idea that your mind has some ability
that you can't tap into consciously,
but you can in some sort of a
subconscious sense.
Someone gives you something and if
you're convinced that it's doing
something positive and it actually will
have some benefit to you of real,
tangible,
measurable benefit and it doesn't seem
to make sense.
There's no mechanism that we can trace.
There's no mechanism.
No,
it's what I found works really well is
I've done a few shows on placebo is for
me,
I found the key is the person gets to
absolve any responsibility for the
change themselves.
So they.
I've done a couple of things where this
new show I have on Netflix now called
sacrifice.
A guy thinks he's got a micro chip
implanted in him,
which is doing all the work.
Uh,
another show I've done is,
was a placebo injections they were
getting.
So they fill the drug is doing the work,
but the key is they don't have to.
They don't think they're doing any work
at all.
This thing is taking care of that for
me.
And that's really powerful because
suddenly it's,
it's that thing of I don't have to do
the person thinking,
I don't have to make this happen myself.
There is no onus on me.
I don't have to do any anything.
This,
this magic formula is somehow doing it
is hugely powerful.
So that.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a,
that's A.
I think that's a big,
big part of it,
which is why a lot of the.
When we,
when we did the placebo program,
we created this whole like I'm fake a
pharmacological building.
We had a building.
We just fitted out with actors and
equipment and stuff to just create this
environment that was going to be
convincing before the injections were
even given.
And these people that had various like
fears or problems or things that would
be just going to just investigate and
see how well the placebo worked and uh,
yeah,
it did.
But that,
that that's a helpful thing.
Feeling.
There's just something in you making it,
making it happen.
Yeah.
Almost like a subconscious optimism or
something like that.
Yeah.
I've,
I've wondered if that sort of mindset
that allows you to experience a
beneficial result of a placebo if that
in some way transfers over to everyday
life events if having this may be
unfounded sense of optimism or this a
bizarrely positive outlook or this,
uh,
almost undo confidence actually can have
some sort of a beneficial tangible
result in the real world in terms of
actual events that take place.
Whether it's because of the way you
interact with other human beings that
they are being influenced by your
positive attitude,
attitude and energy and the confidence
and enthusiasm.
And then therefore things go smoother or
whether it's really some sort of a
factor of the way you interchange with
reality itself.
And that your attitude actually has an
effect on events.
I think it gets vastly overrated.
I'm a big advocate of strategic
pessimism.
I think the the problem with that kind
of the problem with unwavering
self-belief,
yes.
Is that it just doesn't.
That doesn't quite map into how life
works,
I think.
I think the Greeks had this down,
so if you imagine a kind of a graph,
so you've got your,
your y axis going up here of your aims
and things you want to achieve and then
your x axis is just what they used to
call fortune stuff.
That life throws back at you that you
have no control over,
no control at all.
So we are told a lot nowadays that you
just set your goals,
believe in yourself,
visualize this as if we can crank up the
sort of the line that we're living.
Yes,
right up in line with our goals and our
aims and so on.
The reality is there's always life like
pushing back.
So actually what we lead is an x equals
y line.
That that's a kind of more realistic,
I think appraisal of what our life is.
So actually kind of sort of,
I think making peace with that which
allows for all the optimism you want,
but also makes peace with the fact that
at some point that might let you down,
you know,
you can spend your life climbing a
ladder and then realize you had it
against the wrong wall to quote Joseph
Joseph Campbell,
you know,
you can set goals that they may just be
the wrong goals and you may achieve
them.
And then like,
you know,
now what I've got,
a friend who um,
uh,
spend a long time building up a company
and selling it and it'd been driven to
do this all his life because he liked,
needed to sort of achieve,
to feel like,
you know,
that he was a kind of really worth
something that was,
he was all about achievement and then he
sells the company,
achieves that dream and then he didn't
know what to do with his life because
that urge was still there.
Now it had nowhere to go and actually
ended up in therapy because of it.
It was such a strangely a counter
intuitive thing.
So I,
you know,
I'm,
what about changing the world for the
better,
but I think we have to make mental space
for the fact that,
um,
like when,
when Freud credit psychoanalysis,
he wasn't trying to make people happy,
he called it,
he called it restoring,
restoring natural unhappiness.
My life is basically going to be unhappy
sometimes and he was trying to get rid
of unnatural unhappiness as he saw it,
like it sort of neurotic unhappiness and
restore a kind of an easy relationship
to life and fortune.
So to me that's,
that's the case.
I'm always a bit,
was a bit skeptical of the kind of,
uh,
just unwavering positivity.
Yeah.
No,
I agree with you.
I mean,
I think that unwavering positivities
usually delusional.
Yeah.
But a certain amount of positivity at
schools.
Oh yeah,
of course.
A certain amount,
a certain amount of the dangerous.
It's like the faith healers,
right?
So the faith healing thing of you go
away,
you don't take your pills,
and if this condition returns,
which it's going to,
it's your own fault because you didn't
have enough faith right now that's quite
a toxic cycle of self blame.
It's exactly the same cycle that you get
when you read.
Like the secret,
for example,
says quite explicitly,
if these great things don't come your
way,
it's because your self believer wavered
for a second.
You only have yourself to blame.
She's very explicit about that.
Um,
and that,
that's the problem.
It's it,
it's great if you can put it in a
certain context.
If not,
it's sadly can be a recipe,
I think for anxiety and just a feeling
of failure that you don't understand
where it's come from.
Well,
but I was trying to get at was I wonder
if it's a component in a much larger
picture.
Not that it's the one thing like the
key,
like the real problem with the secret is
the idea that you're taking all these
people that are already successful,
they've achieved a certain result,
and then you're asking them,
how did you achieve that result?
Well,
I thought positive and I just really put
my mind to it and I dreamt on it.
They all have this in common.
Well,
you know,
who also thought positive bunch of
losers.
They tried and you know,
they got hit in the head by asteroids or
car accidents or the world turned bad on
them.
That actually can happen too.
Yeah.
So it's just,
you're using,
you have a biased focus group executive
about it.
Yes,
exactly.
It's exactly.
And,
and the,
the idea of setting a goal fixating on
it and ignoring all the haters and
ignoring all the people that will bring
you down is a perfect recipe for failure
as much as it's a common anecdotal,
a story of success.
Well,
the problem with that is if you just
focus on the one.
The thing about human beings I think is
that we really do need other people's
input and interaction and the idea that
you're going to work in a vacuum and
create this great masterpiece without
any interaction with other human beings
as doesn't really.
It doesn't really work like that.
It doesn't because life is active and
messy and ambiguous and ambivalent.
And W I think the trouble is we get hung
up on nouns like happiness or meaning or
even the self,
right?
Because I think,
I think actually these things are verbs
there.
Webby we sell as a verb.
You know,
maybe something that happens dynamically
in the relationships that were maybe
ourself is something that kind of
extends out into the world and is kind
of fluid in that way.
And happiness maybe is.
Maybe that's an activity,
meaning is maybe an activity,
but we,
w we reduce these things to nouns.
Like they're really neat,
easy,
isolated things and uh,
they're really not.
So I can in a lot of the TV shows that I
do,
I'm putting people through like a
transformative process and they're
reacting to kind of really extreme
situations.
And I always had people saying,
oh,
I wouldn't do that love already,
but think it's all fate because I would
never do that.
But they're viewing themselves as this
isolated.
There's just this sort of individual
kind of separated from everything else.
Watching that and thinking how they
behave,
what they're not doing is thinking.
And if I were in that situation with the
same pressures and then that's,
that's amazing that that does changes
that were not there for two,
300 years.
We've had this idea that we are,
these kind of all goes back to like not
being influenced by kings and priests.
Like it was John Locke.
It's like the,
the beginnings of that,
that idea that,
no,
we,
uh,
we should not,
we should have this kind of personal
authority and it's drifted into a
through can't.
I think it's drifted into a really
unrealistic and unfair sense of how
isolated beyond we're not.
We're clearly social creatures.
I,
there's a show on Netflix called the
push,
uh,
which I did,
which was to see whether,
if you create this environment of social
compliance.
So it's a big party,
right?
There's one guy and it doesn't know that
this is being filmed,
that is part of a TV show.
Everybody else is an actor.
And the plot was to see,
could you get him to murder somebody to
push someone off the roof to the death
as far as he's concerned.
Obviously it doesn't.
No one really dies.
Right?
And it just starts where he kind of gets
roped into helping out at this event.
And it's a big high stakes event.
Everyone's in,
um,
you know,
Tuxedos,
but he didn't get the memo for the dress
codes.
We already comes in feeling a bit and
then he gets,
he gets roped into helping out and like
the first thing is asked to do is to
label,
um,
meat filled sausage roll snacks as
vegetarian,
right?
Because they,
the vegetarian ones haven't been
delivered.
So it's just like a little kind of foot
in the door thing and it just builds and
it builds.
And,
uh,
it gets to this point when he's on a
roof having been through this really
dark,
extraordinary and sort of hilarious and
massively anxiety,
juicing journeys,
a lot of emotions you go through and you
watch it and then faced with this
massive pressure to,
to kill this guy.
And I don't want to,
don't want to spoil the ending because
it's a stronger.
But um,
this is like,
it's,
that's what it's all about.
You know,
how your,
how your sense of like the story you
tell yourself about who you are.
It's just,
isn't,
isn't real casual about the new
shipping,
about net are the sacrifice because
anything you want.
But can I ask you one question about
this?
What I mean,
do you feel
a certain sense of moral confusion when
you're trying to talk someone into
potentially and you realize that if this
wasn't a show,
if similar or maybe even more powerful
pressures were in play and this guy was
suggestible and he found himself in very
unusual circumstances where it seemed
like a good idea to kill this person.
Like you're,
you're introducing this thought and
this,
this scenario into a person's mind that
perhaps could go cradle to the grave and
never have that.
It's,
it's kind of the opposite,
what it actually,
it's just hard to about giving away the
ending,
but the,
what it does is actually mentally
rehearse somebody.
What this guy took away from it is the
knowledge that if he was ever in a
situation again where there was anything
like that nature of compliance that he
now has the tools to just like stand up
to it because you need that kind of
promotional.
And likewise for viewers hopefully
watching it too.
That's kind of the idea.
You're all,
we're all emotionally rehearsing it with
him.
Um,
and unless you've been trained in staff
and you know it like that,
you need like an emotional experience of
it to know when that thing happens,
to just have the resources to understand
that you can be manipulated.
These are very.
Although it does,
I realize it doesn't sound like it.
And that showed the purchase.
I mean,
it's kind of like the darkest of all the
shows,
but they are,
they are there for like a good reason.
There's like a,
there's a reason for doing it.
Everybody that comes away,
it was always like,
you know,
that's,
that,
that was a great thing to do.
Best thing I've ever done.
You know these even though the journeys
themselves but do look very dark.
Well he sounds like the guy who had a
positive outlook on it sounds like
it can learn from their mistakes.
Yeah.
But there's some people that when
confronted with some new situation like,
wow,
I really was going to push that guy off
the roof.
Like this is me.
Like I didn't think that was me.
Now I know now I know that I'm capable
of doing that.
If I get manipulated to the point like
wow.
And then they have a lot of like real
confusion and,
and,
and perhaps a lack of faith in
themselves and their ability to make a
decision.
That's Kinda,
that's Kinda my job to make sure that
the framing and that,
yeah,
that's kind of,
you know,
I mean,
I get these ethical questions that are
worth asking.
And ultimately my concern with these,
I've done a lot of these shows where
people are put through these dark
journeys to reach a valuable point,
much more valuable than perhaps the end
of the porch,
which is quite dog.
But um,
the,
my,
my only real concern is their
experience.
So the guy that has just done this new
show,
for example,
I said to him before I came out and
started talking about the show,
I said,
what do you want me to say about your
experience?
And you said,
aside from having my kids,
that is the best thing I've ever done.
But I know other people watching the
show will say,
how can you now,
can you justify that you're manipulating
somebody and why did you just want to
kill you at the end of it?
And that the reality is it's just this
one guy's experience I care about and
that's something that I can manage and
create and make sure that he's left in
the right way.
And also these are people I just like
we'll remain friends with for the rest
of my life.
So it's not like great,
you've done the TV show.
Thank you.
Goodbye.
This is,
there's a genuine,
um,
intimate bond.
Well,
we all,
like,
we all end up falling in love with me
and the production team falling in love
with these people because you're putting
them through this like 10 month
projects.
Half was a little different with them
sacrifice because he,
um,
he thought he was taking part in one
show,
which was a documentary when actually
there was this whole other thing going
on,
but a lot of the time they have no idea
how long was pushed for it.
Like push was.
Well that was only like,
it.
That was like one evening of actual
filming,
but they,
because it was just one light real time
event,
but the preparation for it,
you know,
it goes back a bit.
I did,
uh,
the biggest one was I did a show called
apocalypse,
which isn't on Netflix.
I mean if you go down the rabbit hole,
it'll be somewhere on youtube where we
ended the world for somebody.
So we,
we took control of his,
a news feed,
a TV we filmed like special editions,
tv shows,
new shows that watched,
fed them into a drip by drip,
created the idea of the world was going
to wait and there's going to be this
meteor strike even I could be out in the
cafe and the radio in the cafe because
we'd know we'd be in that cafe.
There's a radio playing with Djs that he
knows that we're talking about this
thing that is supposed to happen.
And then we stage it.
We staged this pyrotechnic end of the
world thing and this kind of a sort of
controlled enough environment we could
get them into where we could stay to
that convincingly.
And then he wakes up in the second
episode to episode thing in this post
apocalyptic seemingly like weeks later
in a hospital,
like everyone's gone.
The places abandoned,
um,
uh,
some infection spreads.
So there is like,
this is the plot and he then lives
through the plot of the wizard of Oz to
find his way back home and the point of
it was this stoic idea of valuing what
you have because this was somebody who
by all reports was,
you know,
Lazy,
selfish,
took advantage of his parents who was
living with never had a proper job.
It was just kinda like needed to value
what he had said.
The stoics would say,
you know,
just rehearsed taking everything away.
So when you returned to the stuff you
have,
you valued that rather than just always
desiring more.
So that was that idea,
kind of writ large,
take everything away and the world.
But again,
like he was transformed by it really
changes.
You're still in touch with this person.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
And so is this,
this is a permanent shift,
permanent shifts.
He ended up being a teacher in a special
needs school that has kind of worked his
way up through and is now like,
you know,
he's getting married and it's just.
Yeah,
it's lovely.
That's crazy.
I'm not that I can take credit for all
of that,
but you know,
it was definitely a big part of that.
Well,
near death experiences are often
incredibly beneficial to people make big
giant shifts in their attitude and their
perception of the world.
And I realize that time is finite and
then it could have been taken away from
them and they feel like they have a new
lease on life.
I mean,
you really can become a totally
different person after something like,
well,
that's what's happened with this guy
fills in the,
in the,
in this new show,
which is also the first,
like brand new thing I've done for,
for Netflix.
There's a couple of other shows.
But what is it called?
It's called sacrifice sacrifice.
So the plot is,
I take this Guy Phil,
who is,
uh,
an American guy,
his father's,
his father's British British links,
but he's an American guy living in
Florida,
Cocoa Beach,
big,
a right wing guy,
strong views against immigration.
And I using these covert psychological
techniques,
try and get him to the point where he
will willingly lay down his life and
take a bullet for an illegal Mexican
immigrant already somebody believes is,
you know,
it's an actor because it's the whole
thing,
whole thing with actors.
So,
um,
so he went through this journey,
which is not a,
it's not a political story at all.
I mean,
obviously it kind of resonates,
but it was ultimately a story about
compassion and,
and uh,
and humanity.
And there's ultimately a very human
moment that either he found himself in.
Um,
and you know,
the guys like made a huge difference to
him.
You know,
it's,
it's a.
So this is,
I got done a giveaway exactly how it
turns out.
The process take it was about 10 months
there for him.
For him it was like maybe three,
four months.
It was like the beginning block of this
year.
But there's like two levels to make any
shows you've got to write the I,
you know,
that this is the plot of the show and
finding that and make that happen for
him.
But you've also got to create this whole
thing has,
it's like the Truman show it,
you're creating a fiction for somebody
that has to be completely convincing.
That's a whole other level of,
of kind of work.
Plus,
you know,
you gotTa make sure this guy is robust
enough to go through something like
that.
So there's a whole vetting procedure
that has to happen without him realizing
what it's all about.
That's a great way of putting it.
Robust bus psychologically,
right?
Yeah.
That is a crazy amount of preparation
and production work.
Is He?
Uh,
it's,
it's huge in the apocalypse show.
That was like one moment when we had to
just make this guys because there was
the idea that there's electrical
interference with the meteors just had
to make his TV pop off in his room,
like just sort of cut out and to do
that,
there were two guys out in his garden
shed.
I'm waiting.
Had to be there all day because I
couldn't come in and out of the garden
because you might see them pulling a
cable at this moment to make the TV go.
But then they couldn't leave because he
might see them,
so they had to spend the night in this
garden shed and this is like after three
months of not having a day off as well.
So that's like a nothing moment than
normal ever remember from the show.
But yeah,
a huge amount of huge amount of work.
I always get people saying,
oh,
it's all fake.
We haven't really done it.
I think it's just that they won't
believe you should actually go to all
that trouble for the paranoid.
Like if you,
if you did that to a naturally paranoid
person or person with a touch of
schizophrenia,
which is why they have to be vetted very
carefully,
very carefully at any point during the
process.
Of course we can like stop it,
I can,
you know,
I can put that would suck,
wouldn't it?
That would 10.
And they see a guy starting to question
reality and look at clouds in an odd
way.
Next thing you know.
Oh boy.
I think,
I think he's slipping away.
Yes.
So yeah,
that's never happened.
It's always been,
it's always been hugely.
Uh,
that is an amazing process though.
I mean,
it's amazing how much prep work is
involved in something like that.
Just set up the radio where they walk
into a place to different news
broadcast.
I mean,
that is,
that's fun.
The Tab most terrifying was the for him
was the kind of end of the world moment
because we had this fake fake radio
broadcast from,
from the BBC and it was just so
convincing.
It was just magic blood go cold.
More of worlds type stuff.
But in this,
like in this thing,
in a sacrifice,
there was a,
like a amazing pivotal moment in it when
he,
um,
we do this staring tests which was
developed by New York psychology
professor.
And the idea is you just,
you might have come across it,
you just stare silently into someone's
eyes for four minutes and it's,
it's the most amazing thing because
obviously the first thing is you get
listed of awkwardness and this kind of
giggling and,
and then that tends to stop and then
you're just facing a human being and
like you've sort of somehow broken
through all the kind of crap.
And then you just see like a person
that's like living and struggling like
you are and someone with a private life
that like,
that's a big thing for me.
Like,
you know,
we,
we go through life seeing people general
generally at their best light,
you know,
generally people will present their best
version of themselves to you.
If you have a couple over for dinner,
you'll tend to see that couple at their
best.
So you had this skewed idea of how
together other people or how impressive
other people are,
how great other couples are compared to
how you are with your partner.
And we missed that like,
because we know for us we have this big
clumsy,
embarrassing,
lumbering giant of a,
of a private life that's just following
us around and it's particularly now,
you know,
with instagram and all that,
people are branding themselves.
So,
I mean it's like,
it's so unfair in terms of the
difference between how you perceive
yourself and how you perceive everybody
else.
Um,
so again,
you know,
there's the store is that we'd kind of a
living out so that,
you know,
it takes like four minutes of this
bizarre staring thing to kind of reach a
moment of just suddenly I think hitting
a point of just seeing another human
being and everything that comes with
that.
And it was a big moment for this guy,
phil going through it.
It was a really.
We tried a couple of things then that
you see in the shoulder don't work out
quite well.
And then um,
and then this a really emotional moment
when he,
he just has this big change.
Yeah.
It's think also just being able to do a
TV show that really like changes
somebody quite aside from how popular
the show is or how well it works as a
show or who watches it,
whatever.
Just to actually feel like,
you know,
at some point in my life I've done it a
positive thing just for one person with
TV,
which is like,
you know,
generally kind of a pretty.
I'm more authentic kind of medium.
So to be able to just do something
meaningful as you know is,
is good.
Well,
listen to,
it sounds amazing.
It doesn't just sound good.
It sounds like quite a work of art that
you've managed to figure out a way to
coordinate all these moving parts and
trick someone into accepting a bunch of
different versions of reality that
you're presenting to get these results.
It said,
well,
I've got a big production crew that
will,
you know,
it's not all of me.
I've got to write the thing and he was
on it.
And so on that,
that the,
um,
the we kind of worked on over the years.
We had small,
like little things that involved a
involve those kinds of plots that,
that was the first show I did,
like that was taking a guy who,
if not as we fill in sacrifice and she's
bringing out someone's here.
Right?
That's really what it's about.
That's kind of the story you're seeing
somebody go through a big change,
but bringing out the hero and the um,
the first show he did like that involve
this guy who at the end of this,
his own journey had been through,
finds himself on an airplane,
is terrified of flying,
but he,
you know,
we created this situation where you had
to be on a flight and you didn't do
anything to do with us.
Everyone's an actor in the plane.
We've got hidden cameras throughout the
plane.
Then there's this,
there is a medical emergency and will
somebody land the plane?
Someone needs to step up and do it.
Yeah.
It's called here at 30,000
feet.
Oh,
I just,
just to talk through the edit because
it's not,
it's kind of a spoiler,
but it doesn't matter.
He,
he,
he does it right.
He rises up,
has this moment.
He goes to the cockpit.
Now he is highly suggestible.
Right?
I've used him because he is suggestible
so I know that I can put them to sleep
in a vertical was by clicking my
fingers.
Right.
He's conditioned to that.
So I step out before he ended the
cockpit,
click my fingers,
he sort of zonked out.
He's got very conditioned to this
throughout the process,
stick him in a wheelchair,
we land the plane,
he wakes up in a,
about to walk into one of those
convincing simulators that they use for,
uh,
for pilot training,
and it's kind of a night flight.
So that was,
we found out that was the most
convincing thing was to have it when
it's dark.
So he now goes in believing is in the
cockpit of a real plane,
30 feet,
30,000
feet up in the air.
He's got the guy on ground control who
is,
you know,
Internet obviously is everybody is
talking him down getting into that on
the plane and he just,
it's just amazing.
This,
this guy as in his mind,
you know,
is landing,
was playing,
saving the lives of 300 people and that
he steps out and then the thing is
revealed to him and it's so emotional.
And then there's a,
you know,
the gaming means that Michael Douglas
Philomena has always been a point of
reference for me.
So he comes out,
there's like a big party of everyone
that's been on his journey,
all these people,
these actors that have been,
you know,
taking it in this direction.
Yeah.
So it was amazing.
So I've,
I've,
over the years kind of work with these
kind of,
uh,
these plots,
these kind of immersive Truman show
style a plots while at the same time
doing stage shows.
I do,
I do a live show every year as well,
which is kind of a bit more like an old
fashioned sort of magic mind reading
kind of kind of show.
Um,
but uh,
yeah they are,
they are these,
you know,
these extraordinary journeys.
But I just do like maybe one a year
because they take,
you know,
they just,
it.
So it seems like not only does it take
too much time,
but it also really,
you rely so heavily on the
improvisational abilities of all these
other people.
Their ability to adjust an act normal
and to be convincing.
Yeah.
And to follow the plot and not deviate
at all.
And the LAS,
because we used for sacrifice worse,
so good.
It's just like,
it's just like in your blood or
whatever,
so,
so good.
And they were like big at the end that
like big sort of aggressive racist biker
characters that we use.
Terrifying.
And uh,
yeah,
but just a hilarious thing of like they
are because they were bikers as well,
so they are big like Harry intimidating
people.
But at the same time they want to know
about the motivation and whether they
did a right listening.
Got Artists bombed audio.
Odd combination.
Wow.
What a fantastic idea for a show.
And so uniquely original.
I mean it just seems like there's so
much work involved in something like
this.
You must obsess over that.
I,
the process is I come up with an idea.
So like let's,
which is normally we normally sit,
I sit with a couple of guys that are at
the shows with.
We normally drive themselves mad
thinking of ideas and then one of us
normally me goes,
oh,
can't we just,
let's just end the world and it zombies
all.
Let's a safe someone we can get someone
to push up off a building or with this
one,
because I'd done the push,
I wanted to kind of do the opposite of
it.
Something that we saving a life and much
more redemptive story than,
than the.
So the idea is the first thing and I try
and combine a really strong dramatic
hook with a really,
like a good reason for doing it.
Otherwise you're just making like a
controversial,
shocking thing for the same.
Which languages?
No interest.
So a,
well that's a beautiful perspective to
that you actually want to benefit
someone through this crazy prank you're
playing on them.
Yeah.
Otherwise,
exactly.
It would just be a crazy horrible.
And there's,
there is like part of the enjoyment of
the show I guess is a little bit of
that.
It's kind of a little bit,
but that's,
that's uh,
the,
you know,
the shows.
I think they have a lot of heart and a
lot of them
thought you were intended to be
beneficial to these people is what
transforms that you have empathy for
these folks.
Yeah.
And you,
you,
you truly care that that alone makes
everything else better.
It makes the whole,
if the whole thing is just like,
I'm smarter than these dummies and I'm
just going to trick them and we've had
that show before many,
many times and make people feel terrible
and it's cringe inducing when you watch
it and you can't look away,
but that you are doing this.
And the end result is actually a
benefits their perspective and actually
might change their life for the better.
That's extraordinary.
Amazing.
Thank you.
Well that's,
that's,
that's the hope.
The way that I do it,
the way that I changed them is through
conditioning.
So I,
um,
this is a technique I've used a lot over
the years.
Have you kind of take the emotional
state you want the person to have at the
end a,
break it down into components and then
attach each one of those to a,
to a trigger.
So this guy,
Phil,
uh,
in sacrifice is using,
um,
I can app which he thinks is sort of
talking to this.
I'm at the microchip.
He hasn't him because he thinks he
thinks we can.
We really do like cut him open and
seemingly.
Yeah,
we just don't,
you know,
it's a placebo.
We don't really put it in.
But now you do cut them.
Yeah.
We caught him and stitch it back up.
Wow.
Um,
I don't think it needs that.
Don't need stitches for.
It's kind of a small car,
but it's a scaffold going in normal.
Um,
so he thinks he's using this app which
is kind of helping motivate him but what
it's doing,
it's attached.
It's giving him this sound like this
little jingle that gets attached to all
those feelings of motivation.
So that means that when he finds himself
in this kind of final scene where he has
this choice to step in and save a life,
that we can have the same jingle on the
radio that plays and you know,
it's like that thing of you hear a song
when you're breaking up with someone and
it's a horrible period of your life and
then five years later you hear the same
solid and it just brings it all back.
That process or obviously like you know,
advertising as the big example of that
is the premise behind something like the
Manchurian candidate that there's some
way they can snap and then you go back
to the state of mind.
That's more kind of,
I guess overtly hypnotic.
That's like a post hypnotic suggestion.
This isn't,
this is more gentle because he needed to
make the decision himself.
The idea was not that it'd be some kind
of hypnotized robot if that would even
work.
Anyway,
you know,
this,
this is,
this is about creating a trigger.
Those feelings of empathy are important.
A lot of the shows about empathy and a
lot of the show is about the desire to
act and then he's,
he finds himself in this situation,
which is extreme.
He has no idea at this point.
It's anything to do with the filmings
finished that will happen in England as
far as the concerned is gone back home.
We had time to forget all about it and
then ends up stranded in this situation
where it all happens.
Um,
and then I trigger these things off.
So I'm giving him this kind of
psychological nudge and then it's,
you know,
what,
what will happen,
will he,
will he rise up and take it like that,
the guy landing the plane.
It's kind of like what,
what,
what ultimately,
you know,
it's that guy's decision and it's also,
I think it's a story about stepping out
of the kind of,
the,
you know,
I guess the show resonates politically,
but it's not a political show that the,
there's like there were political
narratives we get constrained by and we
forget that attitude to the dialogue
between the sides that you know,
where humanity emerges and will we find
truth.
So this is also,
I guess a story about a guy coming out
of his particular sociopolitical
narrative and just finding something
that ultimately is just a human,
a human quality,
kindness,
compassion.
And these are not political qualities.
Although they ended up getting
politicized,
but they're not,
they're not.
I think there are a lot of people are
gonna Watch this and want that to happen
to them.
Like I need some sort of a
transformative prank played on me to be.
I think people do.
We do get caught and ruts right,
and we do get stuck on momentum.
We get stuck following the same patterns
over and over again.
It's very difficult to change your life.
This is the thing that makes us so great
at evolving.
Our ability to adapt is the same thing
that just.
It ties us down.
So like all through life.
So from an early age like we merged in
this world and we're very quickly given
messages about what our relationship
with that ship to that world is.
This is what people are like,
this is what they want from you.
You are not powerful.
The world is powerful,
you know,
and that that is,
it's going to be skewed.
You said that I love this,
that the greatest burden a child has to
bear is the unlived life of its parents.
Such a great thing to your starting
point is this skewed story and then you
just go through life looking for things
that just fit and recreate that.
Those patents because they feel so
comfortable.
You know,
you're what you learned about love from
your parents.
You've start to bring to your adult
relationships and project all that stuff
on a,
on your partner.
If you think about,
you know,
the,
if you've had a nice loving upbringing,
you are getting a ridiculously skewed
version of what love means.
Like we know as adults how difficult it
is raising kids.
We never saw that as kids.
We never saw our parents going off and
screaming at each other.
The next room wants to be going to bed.
We just have this sort of impossibly uh,
hopefully,
you know,
if we've had a,
had a happy one,
we'd get this impossible,
um,
template of what love is and should be.
And then we just dumped that on the poor
adult partners which nobody can live up
to.
So our ability to adapt,
to internalize stories about who we are
and then like mistake that for reality
is just a,
is just what makes living just difficult
and complex.
And also the narratives that come
through fiction narratives from films
and books and songs.
The versions of romance and.
Yes,
particularly with that.
Yeah,
I love the idea that I'm done.
If you never landed Bhutan is a British
philosopher and writer and he said,
you know,
if you go to bed twice a week with your
partner thinking,
oh,
the fuck am I doing with this person,
that's normal.
That's a normal thing.
I like.
To me that's more useful information
than you know,
how to make your relationship perfect.
These things aren't perfect and again,
living,
living with the understanding that you
know,
life is devoted.
What about three times a week,
three times a week.
I think that's probably pretty normal as
well.
In general,
what's the number where you should start
to read?
Five.
Two good nights.
We have two good nights though.
Five nights a hell of a two of them.
She's the best.
Yeah.
What do you do?
Yeah,
I think the.
The narratives that we get from fiction
or they're very confusing to people,
particularly people that are very
romantic,
they have these ideas that their life is
going to be like one of their favorite
films and that that's what they're
looking for.
They're holding out there,
holding out for when the music plays in,
the closeup is there and
and those stories stopped.
Going back to this guy mandible.
Tony wrote a lovely book on this.
Those fit the trouble with those films
that those stories.
They stopped when the people fall in
love and get together.
That's what.
That's when it starts.
That's when the tough stuff starts that
we could do with some good strong
fictional frameworks to sort of absorb
that.
That's when the tufts stop.
It's like it's like death.
It's the same thing,
isn't it?
We have no.
We've kind of lost touch with the
cultural narratives around death that
gave it some meetings and now when it
happens,
it's just as absurd,
scary thing that we don't know what to
do with.
The only narrative we have that we have
absorbed,
I guess,
is that of the brave battle at someone's
fighting,
which is so unhelpful for the person
that's in that situation makes everyone
else made me feel better,
but just adds like eventual failure and
letting everyone else down to this
person's burdens.
It was what they should,
what they should.
What we should feel in that at that time
is you know,
that this is,
this is when we can bring out if we have
the opportunity to bring our stories to
some kind of ending,
you know,
if you watch,
if you watch a film or read a book,
that final scene makes sense of
everything that's happened before.
This doesn't happen in live.
It is kind of.
And so we should be like author of our
stories more than at any point before
death.
And you know,
if we have the opportunity,
what happens is the opposite.
We become like cameos in this story,
you know,
the main characters or our loved ones or
the doctors or people making all these
decisions and we kind of get sidelined.
So yeah,
these fictional or mythical storage,
just these things that just give us a
sense of where our experience fits into
a wider sense of meaning.
We've,
you know,
we've,
we've kind of lost touch with that the
last couple of hundred years and there's
a lot of good stuff that's come with
that because we've embraced,
you know,
science and knowledge at the expense of
superstition.
Of course,
but I,
you know,
we've kind of lost touch of something so
we've lost a little bit of touch with
nature and the natural laws of things
living in dying and I think we as human
beings today are probably more alienated
from particularly the death of farm
animals and things along those lines.
Like where,
where our food comes from,
like actually seeing death.
Even if your dog is sick,
you bring him to the vet,
the vet puts them down,
you know,
all these things that people probably
experienced firsthand for hundreds and
hundreds of years,
particularly like raising animals and
that is done is just completely removed
from the equation.
Those folks.
Yeah.
That sort of embodied dialog or that
dialogue with ecology with nature is
interested in.
There's like view of like what,
what the kind of indigenous peoples,
uh,
well,
like dad,
you have to shame and our view of what
the Shaman is is so skewed by our kind
of western mode.
The,
what the,
the tapping into is not like it isn't
the supernatural.
That's not sort of the,
um,
that's not really the mode what you have
and you still have it in these,
uh,
indigenous peoples that sort of say live
like,
um,
rural Asia and so on that were,
these,
these ways of living is still going on,
is what's,
what's clear is it's not the
supernatural,
it isn't the spirit,
it's,
it's all about a really easy
relationship with the natural world.
So an example of this is a great book
called the spell of the sensuous by
David Abrams,
who actually was a magician originally.
He went out and lived amongst his people
and he eats,
he talks about this and he said there
was a,
he was staying in this compound,
this shamans compound.
And the,
um,
the shamans wife would bring him some
fruit every morning,
but you also had these little like
banana leaves with Rice in and she
would,
she was going off and doing something
else with those and he asked where they
were going and should all those for the
spirits of the house.
Right.
So what,
and then she'd come back and without
them we were just wondering kind of what
that meant and what he was doing.
So one day he just kind of followed and
watched.
Gentry was placing these little pockets
of these little things of rice out
around the perimeter of this compound
and he was watching it and from a
distance and he saw the rice start to
move and yet a moment of like,
oh,
this is the spirit,
what is this?
And then the rise moved along the ground
and you've,
oh,
it's aunts,
it's aunt.
So what she's actually doing,
she's putting out rice for the ants.
So then he had the thought of,
Oh,
it isn't spirits,
it's just ants.
And then you realize now of course the
ants kind of are the spirits,
right?
So this is a house where food is
prepared or they have a lot of,
of big events.
And an ant infestation would be just
disastrous for them.
So the spirit of the offering to the
spirits of the house is a kind of a
dialogue with the answer is going to,
if we were going to put this rice out,
can you just,
if you just have the rise,
if we do this every day,
will you leave us alone?
Um,
and then that's it.
Like it's,
it's kind of that it's quite simple
dialogue and I sort of this lovely kind
of embodied relationship with nature
that of course we're so far from here.
So interestingly,
we do tend to pack a lot of ideas into
the,
you know,
the supernatural even like the
unconscious and depth psychology and so
much I'm a big fan of,
but we can take all this,
the unknown stuff and shove it into
these kinds of bottomless pits.
Whereas actually,
interestingly,
if you trace it back,
it seems like it just wasn't like that.
It was this very,
uh,
well it doesn't,
it depends on what they're doing is
particularly with Sherman Sherman is
concentrating on psychedelic drugs.
They're an Iowaska church and they're
giving people dimethyltryptamine like
this is the,
they are dealing with the supernatural.
A very bizarre
and intense transformative experience
they're putting people through and
there's different like that term Shaman.
It really,
it kind of was very rare,
very rare to be discussed up until about
maybe 20 plus years ago and it seems
like there's been some sort of a
psychedelic revolution over the last
couple of decades and it's almost become
a little bit too popular here were a
bunch of people are profiting from it or
they're.
They're opportunists and they're their
labeling themselves as shaman.
I think the term that they use in Peru,
they call them plastic Shazam and,
and they're,
they're setting up shop and putting
together this Iowasca brew and having
all these Americans come in,
fly in and Europeans are looking for,
you know,
air quote,
spiritual experience and these are not
necessarily pure shaman and the greatest
sense of the word.
It's a different.
This is what we think of when we think
of Shaman today.
We think of someone who conducts a
psychedelic ritual.
Exactly.
Which I know very little of you know,
you've had any experience.
I'm excited if I put,
you know,
real real coffee with DECAF and how
come?
Why haven't you tried something?
Nothing.
Psilocybin.
No,
I never even smoked a cigarette or
anything.
It's,
it's,
it's a real magicians thing.
It's kind of like a pendulum like that
too.
Yeah,
it's very common instead of A.
I think it's like a new robotic control
thing during that period where if you're
going to do it,
you're going to be doing it then and
then,
and then that kind of time policies and
it just ends up being something that
gets missed.
A lot of magicians don't drink.
Don't smoke.
Penn had the strangest response when I
asked him about that.
He said,
uh,
I think we figured out everything we can
from those things already.
But you have it.
Yeah.
You haven't,
you,
you've learned.
We've learned everything we can learn
from these psychedelic trips was with
his perception was you.
I don't know if he's amended that since
then.
This was over a decade ago.
We had this conversation,
but that thought process is fascinating
to me because,
uh,
well,
you mean you're talking about like this
transformative experience that you've
put through people through with these
shows set and setting them up these,
you know,
they think the world is different and
changed and then they changed because of
that.
I think what we're missing is,
uh,
is a,
it's the,
it's the experience of transcendence
that's important.
Yeah.
Really,
religions originally gave people that
there was a time in history where were a
religion was being born and it was
giving people of phenomenal logical,
embodied experience of the transcendent
whatever that was,
whatever that meant.
And then time moves on and then that
kind of moves out of living memory.
And so you kind of have to need to
recreate it,
recreated feelings through practices.
And then there's practices start to
becoming a rituals and dogma.
And by this point you're creating a sort
of recreating a belief,
but the sort of the embodied experiences
sort of kind of faded into the
background.
And then,
you know,
I'm,
I'm a,
I'm an atheist,
but that I could see that what you're
left with thousands of years later is,
is quite easy to knock down.
Um,
I'm kind of poke fun of.
But actually it's at some level,
I think it's,
it is not doing a very good job of
pointing back to the original
experience,
the importance of transcendence.
Now you can diy spiritualize that
doesn't have to be about anything
overtly spiritual,
but like finding something bigger than
yourself in life and throwing yourself
into that thing is how we find meaning,
right?
Meaning trump's happiness or anything
else.
And that might be through your kids.
And I guess this is why people generally
sort of,
we have kids at a certain point,
you know,
our ego gets to sort of step down,
um,
so that,
you know,
that that's.
And if what we,
what we do instead,
I guess hence the interest in these
dodgy Shamans,
we just put it in all the wrong places,
money,
fame,
and so on that don't supply it.
They do not supply those feelings.
Transcendence,
we think they will because we think,
you know,
rich and glamorous life will lift us up
and out of our boring everyday lives,
but of course you know,
they don't work.
There's something.
There's something about that
relationship to the mysterious that even
even me as an atheist and the rest of
it,
I kind of.
It's important.
We have to have that somewhere.
Someone realize that needs to be some
kind of space for that.
It doesn't need to be anything.
I'm spiritual.
It just is a kind of a respect for and
understanding that serving something
bigger than yourself,
whatever,
whatever that is and whoever knows is is
a important part of being human.
I liked it.
That keeps coming back to you.
This recognition of your work as being
something that's bigger than yourself.
You pour yourself into this and through
that experience you somehow transcend
that.
Something comes out of it,
you,
you grow with the creation of this thing
in some way and while it's happening,
you're about as alive as you can be.
Right?
Me,
well I'm,
I'm happy if my breath is decent at four
in the afternoon.
I have very,
very low ambitions with the business
stuff,
but it's.
But it's for the,
certainly for the guys going through it,
other people going through it,
I hope it gives them a profound and
transformative experience for me.
I,
I get very,
I get kind of a bit low if I'm not
actively engaged in something creative
so that,
that,
that is important for me,
but I,
you know,
the painting or whatever.
These are all things that you were
referring to
to the painting and the exact same way.
Something bigger than yourself.
Yeah.
That's projects.
Something to occupy your mind and your
spirit and your creative juices.
Yeah.
It's,
that's,
I think that's a really.
It's a,
it's a vital part of your life.
Making sense of some,
you know,
the people sadly that throw themselves
off buildings.
It's not,
they're unhappy.
It's that they've normally,
there's no meaning has gone that,
that's,
that's the real,
that's the real killer is lack of
meaning and we find meaning through
throwing ourselves into something bigger
and recognizing that.
And you know,
I think maybe the reason why this sort
of work on myth and so on is he's sort
of feeling like it's coming back into
the back into the dialogue now is bs
because it's something that's something
kind of real brackets fictional to kind
of,
you know,
to,
to hang onto these.
This is important.
They are the I think are articulate.
Something that's needs to be recognized
and somehow honored within within life.
Do you know Tyson furious.
He's a British heavyweight boxer who's
the lineal heavyweight champion and he
went through severe depression.
He won the title from Vladimir Klitschko
who had held it for many,
many years and beat him and then felt
like he accomplished his goals and just
went into a real bad funk,
gained a ton of weight,
started drinking every night,
carrying on and got suicidal and was
thinking about driving his Ferrari into
a bridge and then decided that he was
going to make another run at the
heavyweight championship.
And so through all this depression and
suicidal thoughts and all these
different things,
what turned him around was goal setting.
The idea that he had something to work
towards and something to live for,
and then getting in shape and then
forcing himself to be on this path,
try to achieve that goal.
Um,
and then what happened if it takes
place,
didn't December first.
It hasn't happened yet.
The rematch hasn't happened yet,
but he's lost more than a hundred and 60
pounds.
He's,
he's slim and he looks fantastic and
healthy and he was really fat and really
large and very,
very depressed.
And now he's really happy and no
medication.
And that's the craziest thing about it
is we're always searching for some pill
that's going to fix,
fix whatever weird,
funky path the mind is on.
But for him,
what he found was that goal setting,
like having something that you're
striving towards working towards this
danger is though what happens
afterwards.
It's exactly the danger because that's
what he said.
I asked him,
I said,
well,
what if you win?
What if you win the title?
What if you fight deontay wilder and
December first and you beat him and he
become the championship?
Uh,
maybe I'll balloon back up to 400 pounds
again and get depressed and I don't say
that because I'm worried that he's being
honest because he has been down that
road before.
But it's fascinating that he achieved
real happiness from attempting to work
towards these goals and building towards
these goals and having this vision in
his mind.
I think a real thing happening.
And
with Christianity that kind of exploded
a relatively new idea onto the seat and
a couple of thousand years ago,
which to bear in mind.
So prior to Christianity you kind of had
the stoics,
like for 500 years they were the,
you know,
the hugely popular philosophical school
and they're all about bear in mind,
they're also the first election from the
east.
So there's a kind of ideas around like
non attachment and mindfulness that was
sort of differently expressed in a much
more western rational way.
But they kind of reflect some of those
ideas that were going on in Buddhism at
the time.
So the idea of happiness was very much
about your relationship to the current
moment and your emotional state in the
in the moment,
and then also stepping back from her
whole life and it said you couldn't
really judge anyone is happy until
they're on their deathbed.
And then what is,
what is the story that emerged and what
happened with Christianity is for the
first time there was this,
this new message that no,
no,
you suffer now and your reward will
happen in the future.
And it's like,
it's an amazing idea,
particularly if you're suffering.
And that was,
you know,
a time when there was hellenic walls and
it was a time of great suffering.
So an amazingly powerful message.
But like that idea of you can take that
sort of spiritual ladder,
that idea of sort of climbing towards
your,
sort of this shimmering golden haze of
a,
of a reward heaven,
whatever it is off in the distance
that's now the corporate ladder.
Right?
That idea that,
that mode has,
has stayed with us.
We now,
like in England,
I,
I'm not familiar enough with the school
structure here,
but in England when you're 16,
you're choosing your a levels,
right?
Which is what you finished school with
to then decide what you're going to
major in at university in order to then
what job you're going to get at the end
of that to what promotion you could get
and what you're going to work your way
up to.
I'm like,
what is that moment?
What is that point that it's that,
that end.
You know,
we're so we are so fixated
on what's coming and I know this is in a
way it's sort of like,
well,
this is familiar in terms of the
importance of mindfulness and so on,
but it also ties in with like a fear of
death,
death.
Death is.
It's interesting.
Unpacking why deaths frightening because
we're not going to be there when it
happens and all those things,
but it seems to be that it's frightening
because our projects will end.
You know,
the,
whether it's your kids or grandkids that
you won't see grow up or what.
There's always something that's going to
come to an end and the the antidote to
that seems to be just just reappraising
that constant fixation on the end.
So I'm on the,
on the future,
so that's why I'm,
you know,
I,
I hear that and god,
how,
I mean,
how amazing he is.
Found that now,
but I can't help but think and then one
and then what,
you know,
I couldn't agree more about this idea of
working towards something when you're in
school that you're,
you're,
you're almost trying to reach an end
that never comes.
I mean you're,
you're,
you're building for something and also
the pressure that they put on children
to start that off at age 14,
15,
16,
and to pick what you're going to be
doing for the rest of your life and this
idea that one day you're going to air
quotes,
make it and then you're going to make it
and.
But if you did,
you'd be like inferior in that situation
now or that.
This friend of mine I said built up the
company and then sold it.
It was depressed and had to go into
depression at that that need the thing
that has been driving it,
that's still there and that needs
someone to go and it's like you're much
better off having something unfulfilled
that at least is taken care of that need
so you need.
He needs something that's going to be
perpetually a,
you know,
rewarding,
but patch stimulating,
stimulating the human mind needs to
engage in puzzles and and projects and
creative endeavors and all sorts of
different requirements that the mind
has.
I believe that mirror requirements that
the body has.
We think of the body having requirements
like you need some daily exercise.
You need good food.
I think you need some mental exercise
and I think you need knowledge.
You need information,
you need wisdom.
You need that to to.
You need inspiration and inspiration
like when we're talking about all the
different things that you can do to
someone as a hypnotist or that you can
do to someone when you're putting
together these shows and changing their
perspective on things through these
transformative events.
That's,
in a lot of ways,
it's a type of fuel for the mind and
inspiration is a type of fuel for the
amount,
a great book.
It's fuel for the mind,
you know,
um,
even sometimes people mean this fast
food culture that we live and we like it
in a little tiny meme,
a little inspirational meme on someone's
instagram page says,
oh,
I like that.
That's what I like,
that it makes me feel good.
It gives you a little bit of a,
uh,
some nutrition for your mind,
but at the same time is,
it's squaring that with how
that life is,
it's actually really ambiguous and
complex and that's,
that to me is the,
that's the big thing to become,
I think more conscious of what you'd
love.
It's probably the best we can really aim
for us to become more conscious of,
of the things that beset us because the
stop around conscious of is the stuff
that owns us.
Yes.
And the stuff that we're unwilling to
acknowledge.
Yeah.
That's the stuff that comes back and
bites us in the background constantly.
Yes,
absolutely.
The model of I'm psycho psycho analysis.
I love it as he talks about the god,
so he was very interesting talking about
like the,
the,
the Greek model of the gods because they
didn't necessarily like worship the gods
and believed that they were like real
definitive in the way that we might talk
about God now,
but they,
what they were doing was honoring these
different,
sort of like clusters of energy,
like,
like the god of Eros,
so that's you,
you honor Eros because it's important to
honor the sort of,
the erotic urge.
And if you don't,
if you don't honor that,
it's going to come back and get you.
So the,
the homophobic televangelists that gets
caught in bed with some guy and at some
massive scandal,
it will come back and bite you.
If you just want to bury something in
you,
it will come back and bite you.
And I liked that,
but it,
it,
it just means that it,
you know,
life is,
I'm ambivalent and complex and I think
the best we can do is,
is try and be conscious of that and not
be constantly reducing things to uh,
so easy packages.
But at the same time,
how else do you navigate forward
without,
without reducing things to an easy
story,
that's the only way you can make sense
and move forward is to,
is to have an easy story.
So it's,
it's a,
that's like a whole lifetimes,
you know,
preoccupation there.
Yeah,
it is all messy.
Yeah.
We do love to similar things down to a
nice tasty little easily digestible
package,
but the reality is when you open that
package there,
every package is intensely complex.
Like every single situation has all
these different interacting factors that
led to that situation taking place.
And if you take them all into
consideration and really dwell on it,
like you just get paralysis by analysis.
Exactly.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly,
exactly.
But a consciousness is awareness is
probably the most weekend we could aim
for,
at least in our own lives.
God,
you can only.
You can only sort your own life out
here.
It probably also plays into hypnotic
suggestibility in my own work,
in terms of suggestibility,
because we are,
we're looking for direction,
which is essentially that the simple
message that easy message was.
So we just kind of kind of wired to grab
hold of that and absorb it.
Just kind of want to hit me.
It's like a director of somebody giving
you something you know you can hang onto
when you're just kind of confused as
sort of essentially I guess what,
what suggestibility is your essentially
confused and looking for an answer and
at that moment someone is giving you the
answer in the right way.
But correct me if I'm wrong,
there's no clear scientific
understanding of what hypnosis is.
It's not like there's like you can
clearly show like this is what's
happening and that's how it works and
this is why it works.
There is.
I don't think there's an easy answer to
that,
but there is like a said,
forget the hypnotist and the performers.
There is a hole that big body of
clinical work investigating it because
it's clearly a thing yet suggestibility
is part of the human experience,
but as to what it is.
Well that's kind of.
That is kind of the question because you
can't ever quite climb inside a person's
head and.
No,
but I like I,
in one of the shows I did,
I did a show where it took you Sirhan
Sirhan who assassinated Bobby Kennedy.
So he said he was hypnotized by the CIA.
So it was like that.
That's his story right now as a whole.
He sets out how,
uh,
how that happened.
So we took that said,
well,
let's,
let's do it.
Let's set up a and assassinations
whether or not is it plausible,
I mean,
is if you take some of the tiniest
possible,
do you believe that we did it?
We got a guy and the show starts with a
big audience of people that are up for
taking part.
I find the most suggestible person in
the audience.
And by the end of it he finds himself in
a packed theater.
Uh,
no it doesn't.
No,
it's being filmed.
He's got what he thinks is a real gun,
which he thinks is a thing that is going
to carry with them in a bit of filming
is going to do later.
But he has a real gun on him and we set
off these little triggers in the same
way.
So has a hand said happened to him,
right?
So there's a girl with a Polka dot
dress.
Uh,
there's a sound that he hears,
which we had a someone's ringtone next
to him.
The little triggers that they had
apparently implanted.
What would you do?
Would that guy.
He has no idea.
This is being filmed as know as part of
the show isn't a packed theater.
We've got Stephen Fry on stage,
right?
His,
he's the guy that's going to get
assassinated.
So he's on it.
He's wearing scrubs and everything.
He knows that he may get assassinated at
some point during the show.
Will the guy do it?
And he does it right.
He stands up and does it.
He fires.
What is a real gun?
A weird,
weird thing of expecting pandemonium
from the audience.
And there's that weird normalcy bias
that kicks him enough.
I just sat there thinking,
is this part of the show?
We had all these crowd control people
and like nothing happened,
but he did it like,
you know,
he uh,
he shoots it.
But that was good as I mentioned that
because at the beginning of it we're
doing these tests with a guy,
um,
and you know,
the people in the room and sort of
looking at what is,
what is going on with it Moses.
So we had this,
we had an ice bath and I hypnotize him
and told him under hypnosis he'd be able
to come to begin the ice bath and you
wouldn't feel the,
the temperature.
And I had no idea if you would,
because that's a real test.
Like if he's just sort of playing along
at some level,
you're not gonna,
you're not gonna get an ice bath like
that.
Even if it's even if there's some kind
of physiological state you can tap into
to make that possible that some people
with training can do as a first time
just step in and do it.
He's gonna he's not gonna be able to do
that.
And I had these two clinical hypnotist
with me.
They hate actually might made a bet on
whether or not you do it.
They thought he wouldn't do it.
I had no idea.
And he did do it.
And it really kind of,
sort of three me,
he was comfortable being in this ice
bath and see the temperature.
We had him kind of linked up to a
thermograph thing.
We had to pull him out if he was at a
certain temperature.
I think if it got to whatever it was,
50,
whatever that means we had to,
we had to take him out.
Um,
you know,
and that was,
that was extraordinary.
So although I think of it in very
behavioral terms,
I don't think of it as any kind of
special.
We had state.
Then it's like,
well then you know,
what was,
what was going on with that guy?
Well it's,
it's a physiological possibility that we
can do that because somebody can do it
through lots of training.
So maybe it just kind of with this guy
cut to the chase and he was able to just
do it.
But I don't know what the next guy do
it.
Probably not.
I don't know.
What about the,
the ethical
complications that are involved in
having a guy literally performed murder?
I mean,
he doesn't,
he's not actually do because it's an
actor.
He doesn't,
he doesn't know that he's not performing
murder.
He thinks he's a murderer and then you
put it on television.
Yeah.
You have a murderer.
Yeah,
he's a murderer.
I mean there's a,
there's a good kid that's a show where
he is being like completely conditioned,
but that's terrifying
that a,
this is possible and they'd be to this
person that has never experienced
anything like that before.
Finds out that it's possible for him and
that he actually squeezes the trigger
and watch a Stephen Fry fall to the
ground.
The squibs go off and he thinks he's a
murder.
And look,
if you follow the logic that the FBI is
used because the FBI has used similar
logic to talk some pretty mentally
challenged people into detonating fake
bumps that were purchased from the FBI
and those people are in jail for life.
And this is a thing that happened in
Dallas.
There was a young man who was very
suggestible and uh,
he had some serious psychological
problems probably.
And he was a radical and he wanted to
become some sort of a terrorist,
whether it was al Qaeda or isis or
whatever.
And the FBI infiltrated this guy his
life and set him up and got him,
or whatever organization was with the
CIA or FBI,
they or they organize some sort of an
artificial bomb.
They got this bump to him,
had him set up the bomb,
and then gave him this ability to
detonate it.
He goes to detonate it and then they
arrest him.
So there was no bomb.
The bomb didn't exist.
They talked him into doing it
and they genuinely invested in many
genuinely good,
genuine jail for live.
They talked him into doing it.
They provided him with the bond.
The bumper didn't exist.
It wasn't a real bomb.
It wasn't going to kill anybody and they
took this person and essentially did a
version of what you did.
But it wasn't funny.
It was.
It wasn't for a television show,
but through the same intent,
through this guys are different intent.
Hopefully.
Well he might.
For him,
the intent was to kill
and the intent to kill Stephen Fry or
the intent to kill innocent people.
He was going to get with his bomb.
Essentially.
There were both talked into doing this.
No real evidence that this guy would
have ever done it without the FBI or CIA
or whoever the fuck else it was.
Yeah,
but if,
if,
if that had ended with them stepping in
and going,
okay,
we're going to stop you here.
This was an experiment.
Yes,
you've been conditioned to do this.
We wanted to see if you would.
You have done it and now he is a very
careful and delicate dad thing to make
sure you're okay.
That would be a different story and
somehow the ends would then it would be
like a maybe even a fascinating and
valuable thing to do if,
if the guy was fine at the end of it and
happy with it and it wasn't in jail,
well that's kind of more of the world
that we're in here and I'm not making a
judgment on what you're doing.
I think what you're doing is awesome,
but I mean,
I think it's fair.
I think what they did is kind of fucked
up and not just fucked up but crazy that
this is a waste of resources.
I mean,
maybe I'm incorrect.
Maybe this person on that path.
Anyway,
and they recognized it and they stepped
in,
they said,
listen,
this guy is going to do something and
we're going to help him because we need
to get this guy off the streets,
so let's show that he's capable of
detonating a bomb and killing a bunch of
civilians and will provide him with
whatever he needs.
Then we'll get them.
Maybe they did it that way.
I don't know.
I don't really.
You know,
obviously I wasn't there when all this
was going down,
but it seems eerily parallel.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah.
My,
my,
my concern is I guess what makes
hopefully what makes this shows
compelling,
these sorts of questions,
the sort of implications beyond a
controlled thing with one guy who is
fine.
Also it opens the door to the
possibility that this has been done in
the past was Manchurian candidate
possibility.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
I perspective you must think it's
possible.
Right?
Well,
I often making that show I sort of felt,
well,
that work,
it doesn't mean that his story is true.
Of course.
It doesn't really necessarily have to
relate to that at all,
but.
But you did.
It was kind of,
it kind of works.
It worked,
yeah.
Why did you write a book about
happiness?
I wrote a book about happiness because
the,
that makes it really resonated with me.
I was,
I like,
I,
I studied law.
I was supposed to be a lawyer and I uh,
graduated and I kind of was living in
Bristol,
this lovely city in England and I'm
making my living as a magician because
that wasn't the hobby that I had started
and I was just kind of thinking what I
need to some point with this grow into a
job.
I don't know,
but I know that my priorities are just
kind of,
I want my life.
My Dad used to feel like this is good,
everything's in the right place and this
is kind of an enjoyable and worthwhile
pastime and,
or worthwhile existence.
And I never really thought beyond that.
So I've never had any kind of ambition,
genuinely have any,
any salt,
which is why,
you know,
I haven't really,
I'm not a whole goal setting thing
particularly.
So.
But the trouble with thinking like that
as you grow up and become successful
with what you do is you start to feel
like a kid,
like everyone else is a grownup and
you're the kid and,
and slightly embarrassed that you don't
seem to care enough about the things
that everybody else cares about.
The businessy things and the viewing
figures into this,
I,
my interest was genuinely am I enjoying
what I'm doing and is it worthwhile?
And then I read the stoics and although
that's not like the central message,
it's a big part of their,
what they write about,
you know,
not,
not trying to control things that are
out of your control,
not attaching yourself to things that
leave you kind of emotionally
vulnerable.
Um,
and you know,
just your relationship with the present
moment and so on.
And it really resonated.
So I,
uh,
I read it,
I read a lot and it took me off into
other directions that I started writing.
And I wrote this book on happiness after
it took me three years to write it while
I was on tour for three years.
But blocks of blocks of writing,
not like three solid years.
It also,
that meant by the end of it I kind of
had and changed and felt differently and
I think for anyone that knows about
stoicism and it's so immensely valuable
resource in terms of if what you want is
a sense of feeling centered in a kind of
emotional robustness in your life.
And uh,
you know,
if you suffer from anxiety and so it's,
it's,
it's phenomenal.
I think there where it,
where it's slightly doesn't deliver is
the importance of anxiety.
It's all about avoiding anxiety.
That their image of happiness was a sort
of tranquility.
Avoiding disturbance that actually cause
disturbance is really important.
Anxiety's important in life because how
do you change?
How do you grow other than a.
unless some anxiety triggers that you
know,
lets you know that something's wrong.
If we just look for security all the
time.
And I say this because I know I'm like
this,
like this is my,
my problem is that I'm too.
I'm very good at avoiding stress,
very good at avoiding anxiety.
But the danger is,
I don't know,
am I going to grow or,
you know,
I'm just going to just be too
comfortable.
That's not,
you know,
there's not necessarily a good thing.
Um,
so,
uh,
so yeah,
by the end of the book I was,
I kind of could feel the edges of
stoicism in terms of,
uh,
the importance of anxiety in a,
not just living to comfortably,
but it is a.
and that's not,
you know,
they were movers and shakers,
like there are people that changed the
world.
Marcus Aurelius,
greatest philosopher,
king,
an emperor most powerful man or ever was
probably ruled the earth and was,
uh,
was,
one of the great stoics.
So they're not like,
it's not a recipe for complacency,
which you can often sound like when you
talk about this kind of tranquility and
non attachment.
But,
uh,
it is,
it's,
uh,
it's just,
it's a very robust kind of language.
They talk about being like a rock where
the waves and lashing against you and I,
I prefer the image of sort of don't.
If you know Martha Nussbaum,
who's an American philosophy,
he writes a lot about these things,
but she,
she talks about being more porous,
like a rock that the waves,
the water can move through.
And I think that's a more helpful image.
I think that's a,
that's a good way I think of stepping
out into life is if you can have a,
a sort of a robustness,
but at the same time,
that kind of uneasy porous relationship
with what's going on that gives you that
easier relationship to fate and fortune
and all those things that they used to
honor and recognize so much more than we
do now because we don't read tragedy.
So we don't think in terms of those
things.
It's all just,
you know,
pride and Hubris now that they had
lessons about back then and uh,
you know,
uh,
but I think that's a really.
I think that's a,
that's a good,
that's a good starting point for life.
So I wrote,
I wrote this book happy it is.
It's actually just become available in
the,
in the US on Amazon.
I don't think you find it any bookshops,
but um,
because of the like I'm to hopefully
doing a broadway show next year and
these netflix specials and things that
are,
you know,
so it,
it is now available.
Um,
and uh,
and ironically,
the moment I finished writing it,
I was out giving talks on happiness,
feeling oddly sad and I couldn't work
out why.
And it was because this amazing three
years writing project had ended and I
realized,
yeah,
I.
The importance of some kind of creative
pursuit or something that brings you out
of yourself is so important.
That's fast.
Meaning that in the embracing of the
anxiety of the difficulty of the task
and finding upon it
completion,
that you feel sad.
That oddly a oddly sad.
Well,
it's kind of proof of concept that,
right?
I mean,
with what you're saying is like in this
theme that you keep saying over and over
again that putting yourself into
something bigger than you,
something,
something that you're attempting to work
through and that through this difficulty
and all the struggle and trying to put
this something you,
you,
you gained some sort of intangible
benefit from them.
You feel like you,
you seem like you're some of the.
Seeks out those things.
You seem like you've always immersed
yourself fully and things that would,
that would do that.
Yes.
I'm a firm believer in the importance of
difficult tasks.
I think,
uh,
I think seeking comfort is one of the
worst things a person can do in terms of
achieving overall happiness.
I think overall happiness,
a lot of it comes through this amazing
sense of wonder and the unknown and
possibilities and working towards things
with this embracing of having no idea
how the,
what the result is going to be.
No idea where this is going to go and
being genuinely nervous about it every
step of the way.
And do you find that there's normally
being,
having the language for something means
that it doesn't come naturally because
if it,
if that came entirely naturally are the
things I'm saying,
if they completely just,
I'd always been like that.
You wouldn't have the language because
they'd just be entirely unconscious.
So you found this is stuff that you've
found and then learn to articulate,
but because it does not,
it's not an easy thing.
It's not an not an intuitive thing that
maybe life is,
is essentially difficult.
And these lovely happy moments we have
are wonderful,
but they're not the kind of.
They're not the central force of life,
which is that it is,
it is difficult.
I not.
And if you want to philosophy of life,
it has to work in those has to work at
the difficult moments,
isn't it?
Otherwise it's not really.
It's not really going to support you.
I think it's also the attitude in which
you embrace those difficult moments and
how you approach them.
You know,
if you,
if you relish them and understand that
there's going to be some genuine benefit
from getting through these and whether
it's a physical thing or a mental thing,
whether it's a creative thing,
whatever it is,
as difficult,
like just embrace this massive struggle
and and enjoy this.
Just the puzzle of it all,
the,
the majesty of the unknown,
and then when you get through it on the
other end,
you get a different level of happiness.
He had this powerful earned
because she's grown and grown and
you've,
you've moved forward and you don't,
you don't,
you don't cross the road on your own
without having to let go of your
mother's hand at some point something.
Well,
this is,
this is the death and resurrection,
isn't it?
That's why these myths do have some
resonance.
Yes,
something has die before something new,
before something you can grow.
You have to,
something has to be let go of in order
to step forward.
So if you're going to grow,
you have to,
there has to be anxiety and disturbance
and some kind of some sort of death in
the metaphorical sense.
Yeah,
that's tough.
It doesn't come easily.
No,
it doesn't come easily,
but that's also what's beautiful about
it.
If it just came easily,
I don't think it would be appreciated.
Exactly.
You wouldn't be doing it and there's all
this resistance to even engage in it in
the first place.
I mean,
it's hard to write the first word of a
book,
right?
The first word.
Sometimes you just sit in there or
anything you're trying to do,
get it.
The first step of a 10 mile run.
All those things are the most difficult
thing.
Once you're.
Once you're going,
it's not nearly as hard.
It's getting going.
There's something about overcoming all
this anticipation and all the weirdness
of it all,
you know,
and then once you do it and you realize
you can do it,
it enriches you in all your future
attempts.
So something like you deciding to run a
marathon would help you decide to write
a book.
Like all these different things are
interconnected.
The poet,
a real random area,
real cut talks about him
was loved this image of like some people
live in a big room,
some people live in a small room and
some people just like just pace up and
down by the window.
Kind of write that.
Although I do a lot with my life,
but I think instinctively I'm the guy
that's just sort of pacing up and down
by the window.
I'm instinctively how so in that I'm,
I'm a little shy and I kind of.
I'm very good at avoiding.
I just think you're smart.
To avoid
no shy is a lot of it is like,
look,
the interaction between human beings is
so who knows what the fuck's going to
happen?
You know what I mean?
You,
you,
you don't know how people are going to
perceive you.
There's potential bad feelings that
could come with that is there's all
sorts of weird social anxiety and social
cues that you have to read and the
complications of those.
Make sure you get it right.
Don't want to get it wrong.
Don't want to be too rude,
don't want to be too forward.
Don't want to be too shy.
Ramped up.
It's A.
I think it's the case with everybody.
I mean the,
the,
the reason for shyness is there's a
terrible feeling when you're rejected,
you know,
the meeting,
someone who doesn't enjoy the way you've
presented yourself as an awful feeling
that will haunt you for hours if not
days.
Three in the morning I've had
interactions with people and then two
weeks later I'll be putting gas in my
car.
Just go,
what did I say?
Why did I say it like that?
Like,
who knows?
Like that's all of that is there's a
reason why people have some sort of a
weird anxiety about interactions.
Also the stuff that,
which is why that the difficulty is so
worth embracing because if you can,
if you can,
if you can embrace it,
that's where there is a kind of oddly
sublime space because that,
you know,
that's the real stuff of life and that's
the stuff that actually binds everyone
together and that the,
the,
the happy moments.
Well,
they might just be happy because you
know,
she's great and wonderful,
but you might just,
you just haven't got all,
got all the information at that point,
right.
That's kind of what's going on.
So those,
when we,
when we're embroiled in the difficulty,
I think that's when we're most human and
it doesn't necessarily make it any
easier by its nature,
but there is a real value to that.
There's a level of growth and a kind of
sort of just a voice somewhere in the
background that these,
or just as a note of this,
this is,
this is what binds everyone together.
And I think the,
as you said,
yeah,
it's a better type of happiness,
but it doesn't,
it doesn't come easy.
But I think life is about growing up is
about tolerating ambiguity,
isn't it more than more than anything.
When we're infants we scream and someone
comes in and gives us the thing that
makes us feel good.
And uh,
there was a British and a child
psychologist called a Donald Winnicott,
who's sort of,
kind of appeared after Freud and that
there's a lot of,
there was a lot of people felt so guilty
and terrible after Freud was damaging
the kids and he had this great message
of light.
You've actually what the mother or the
principal caregiver needs to be as good
enough.
What she actually needs to do is to
gently let down her infant,
right?
Because if you,
uh,
if you,
if you just grow up thinking that every
time you screamed,
someone's going to give you what you
want.
If you make enough fuss,
you just get what you want.
That's not a very healthy way of growing
up into adult life or becoming a leader.
Um,
so instead what the,
what your mother caregiver needs to do
is to,
is to let you down,
is that needs to disillusion.
You need to learn.
Sometimes I scream and I won't get those
things and that,
that's okay.
And you know,
um,
so likewise,
you know,
in life,
like living with disillusionment is
like,
that's,
that's fine.
That's how it is.
And if we don't have that,
if we live out this sort of fantasy that
we owed,
we're owed something should,
why load,
right?
That the secret that I did at
universities arranging itself around our
banal hocking wishes or,
and it's always like actresses and
obviously,
and the fact that she sort of says,
oh,
this all goes back to Plato.
The,
they couldn't have been any any further
from the idea of a wandering all these
kinds of material gains.
So it's fascinating how this subject
repeats itself in some sort of a strange
intermittent cycle where people start
talking about manifesting things with
your mind and put it in La.
I don't know if that's a thing.
Well,
it's recently,
it seems to be working its way back
around again where it was.
It was outside of the conversation for
quite a long time.
But now it seems to be coming back again
where people are always looking for
reasons why certain people are
successful.
And that's a big one.
The big one is this,
this idea that people can manifest
things with their mind and you know,
when it comes from,
again discussing this with people who
have become successful and they're
looking for a reason as to why they're
successful
and it's very hard to accredit luck
would show it's in their success.
Yeah,
well it's an element analysis,
the whole story,
but the secret thing
and element,
the power of positive thinking is an
element.
All these things are elements,
but they're all combined with
circumstance,
luck,
genetics,
cultural interactions,
the way human beings,
they're just the time of the year you
were born.
You know what I mean?
There's so many different factors.
There's so many things that can lead to.
I mean,
and also where you're born.
I mean you do where,
where are you living?
I mean all these things have a huge
factor in your success.
Try being a entrepreneur in Ethiopia.
I mean,
it's a different experience than being,
you know,
a,
a tech startup guy in San Francisco.
It's clearly one of them has an
advantage and there's a lot of those
things that play into each other and to
say,
well,
you know,
the guy in Ethiopia,
he just wasn't thinking about it the
right way.
He didn't,
he didn't,
he didn't make a wish board and put his
pictures of his,
uh,
his house was Ferrari in front of it or
yeah,
whatever the fuck is trying to.
It's,
it's an,
it's the infant's urge.
It's screaming into the and the universe
will provide if there's some way that
the universe doesn't get,
that should be our starting point of
living,
but surely the universe doesn't care.
What's the perspective enhancer?
The universe in,
in and of itself is a prospective
enhancer minutes.
If you can go somewhere in the country
where there's no light pollution and see
the Milky Way,
you get this.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
This is a lot bigger than I'm thinking.
It's,
I think it's one of the real problems
that we have with our society with
electrical lights that sort of blind out
the stars.
We don't get humbled that the book I
mentioned spell of the sensuous.
This guy,
David Abrams,
who was out living in rural East Asia,
he described at the very beginning,
this amazing image.
He was living in this hot and it was
just,
he wakes up in the middle of the night.
There's any,
just kind of,
I guess being there for a night or two
and he's in this patty field which has
become drenched with water,
with rain.
He steps out and you have this
incredible star filled clear sky,
which is reflected.
It's pitch black apart from that,
right,
so a star filled sky.
It's reflected perfect like a,
like a mirror in this drenched enormous
battlefield that is this fireflies
everywhere in between.
Flying around,
right?
These little little specks of light and
they had no sense of like what was up,
what was down,
which had totally disoriented.
This feeling of just falling through
space.
It's a great opening to the book.
Yeah.
We don't get a lot of that.
We don't get along.
We.
We missed that part.
Galactic part.
We really do.
It's so unfortunate.
Whenever I'm out in the country and I
look up,
I see it.
I go,
Oh,
I was in Utah a couple of months ago and
it was,
we were way in the mountains and it was.
There was no light,
just nothing,
and you look up.
It's just Phil Stars.
Every inch of the sky had stars on it.
It's just,
it's.
It's so humbling and I think it's such a
powerful image for human beings and it's
inspired so much,
so much pondering throughout human
history and so,
so much philosophy and so much so much
of the way people interpret our position
in the universe is based on this image,
this undeniable image of the cosmos that
it's so magnificent and yet in our
amazing technological society that we've
created,
we have a side effect and that side
effect is light pollution.
That light pollution has shut off one of
the most magnificent inspirations that's
available in the natural world.
It's available to us every night.
Instead,
we block it out with fucking seven slash
11 lights and
and that in touch with that,
not just,
not just that,
but the wider sense of the that the
mystery that is represented by.
Oh yeah.
I don't know everything I'd done
everything I know.
Then sadly,
what do we have?
We have people like me have magicians
doing tricks and psychic mediums.
We're tending to connect with the dead.
That's like our,
our tawdry onset to the providing a
sense of mystery there.
Just hustlers.
It's horrendous.
I sat in a studio audience wants and uh,
watching a psychic.
It was one of those TV filmed ones where
there's,
where there's an audience was just like
said before filming starts.
He came out and he said,
so is there anybody here that's hoping,
you know,
hoping that someone's going to come
through and all these hands go up and he
just asked people,
so what are you hoping will come
through?
Okay,
what do they look like?
Is there anything.
Because I'll let you know if they come
through.
Is there anything I can ask?
Any bit of information they could give
me that nobody could possibly know that
will prove to you it's them.
Yes.
He,
he drowned and he was wearing a red
sweater.
Okay,
well I'll let you know if he comes
through and then they start filming and
he just says all those things to them
and uh,
I think about the reason why that stuff
is,
is like people do believe it is that the
lie is so ugly that it's so much easier
to believe something amazing must be
going on there.
Then just is it,
is it just that ugly,
empathetic ally?
It's such a,
it was such a,
it was such a horrible experience.
So many of them them.
Yeah,
I mean they have a television shows
where there was a medium television show
where this woman was connecting people
with their dead relatives and it was so
fake.
They're just,
the,
the questions were shitty.
It was so poorly thought out.
It wasn't just a lie was a live vitally
moron.
That's a shame.
That's the it.
Oh,
that was,
I in one of my shows I had um,
I got like 50 people up on stage had
like a,
like an audience thing set up on stage
and I'm,
we're doing medium shit with them and
providing like,
like very accurate information.
But at the same time saying,
I am,
you know,
I'm lying,
right?
You'll,
your grandmother's telling me what,
she's not telling me anything.
I'm making this up,
you understand?
And then after the,
so he's got to be.
It was an interesting kind of like.
Right,
right,
right.
And then afterwards,
I think it was the first night of doing
the show,
I went out the stage door and I was
talking to people there and there was a
girl who'd seen the show and she said,
will you,
um,
I wonder if you could put me in touch
with my dead grandmother?
And I said,
Oh God,
well,
I hope you understand from what I've
just done that I don't,
I'm not really doing it.
That's kind of the point she had on.
And I understand,
I know you can't Redo it,
but would you be able to put me into
Jesus' eyes an amazing capacity for just
this kind of dissonance?
Well,
that's how cults work,
right?
I mean,
that's the only way they can work.
Once you get Ahold of the manuscript and
you,
you read whatever it was,
whether it's mormonism and Joseph
Campbell,
the 14 year old boy who found golden
tablets that contain the last work of
Jesus,
only he could read with his magic seers
stone.
If you,
if you,
you know,
if you have any critical thinking left
in you at all at that point,
you just,
you put the book down and go,
what the fuck am I doing with my life?
But people don't want that.
They want,
they want the,
the,
the universe is so open ended and the
possibility of your,
your existence expiring at any moment
and you just vanishing into nothingness.
And this consciousness which is
literally stopping the lights go black.
And that's it.
It's so terrifying to us that we,
we would prefer some nonsensical,
unrealistic version of something but
rigid.
So we know how to follow it and a bunch
of other people follow it as well.
And we have this community of people
that fall away and we gain comfort in
that.
And some very,
very strange way.
There's a,
um,
that's sort of an for me and an
unexpected,
um,
comfort that comes with this sort of,
the meaninglessness of it,
which I've sort of recently kind of
found that,
that all of the people in your life and
the people that like people that you
work with and see a lot of,
but that like annoy you and end up being
like a cock,
a constant source of niggling irritation
like we,
you know,
we have people like that or people that
we kind of admire or maybe you're a bit
intimidated by or um,
or like Fitch is going to be the peak.
They were gonna,
they're gonna be the people that just
kind of populated your life at what
point.
And it will amount to no more than that,
but there'll be,
they'll be the people that were there
and,
and it's,
it's hard to articulate,
but it's,
I find that like a,
it's a lot easier to kind of love.
It's a lot easier to love when you
realize that it isn't the end of the
day.
It's all.
Yeah,
none,
none of that's gonna.
None of going to matter.
The,
the,
the guy that's annoying you everyday is
these,
that's going to be,
that was that guy that was with you all
your life.
Kind of annoying,
but that was one of the,
one of these people and the puppet July.
I find it a very,
very powerful,
uh,
kind of just just reset in terms of sort
of attitudes towards people that
engender any kind of nervousness,
irritation,
intimidation,
any of those things.
It's like a,
yeah,
these are just,
these are my sounds,
but these are,
these are,
these are my fellow people,
these will be the people that,
these would be the characters that
people that populated my life.
And then that's kind of a nice thing.
So that makes sense.
Does it,
does.
So in embracing data,
there is no great grand meaning to it.
All.
This sort of intimidation doesn't,
it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
Their religious going through their own
shared as well and I'm just a character
in their lives,
but that's kind of Nice that like,
oh,
this guy was,
this person was with me every day.
Or even that famous person that maybe I
never even met,
but like how weird that that was just
like a force within my life at that
person represented something,
you know,
these,
uh,
um,
said it's just a lot easier to sort of
go out in the world with love,
which is ultimately what we need to try
and do with that thought.
I think
don't listen.
That's a great attitude because anytime
you can have less annoyance by a person
who's just,
whether they're ignorant or confused or
agitated or whatever's causing them to
behave in a way that's uncomfortable for
you,
anytime you can just sort of just,
I Quito that and just sorta look,
relax,
and let it roll off you and just keep
moving and go,
uh,
what are you going?
Do you know what I mean?
That's one less thing you have to
wrestle with in your psyche.
I mean,
that's just,
that's just a recipe for emotional
success,
period.
Yeah.
Well,
this,
the stomach are there.
If you could only control your thoughts
and your actions.
So powerful,
isn't it?
Anything else?
What other people do where they think
everything else outcomes are not under
your,
not under your control,
so you can decide that those things are
fine and that's such a,
a like to really let that idea drop into
the soul that,
oh,
it's fine.
What if it's fine if my partner handles
stress battling drives me and what if
that's what did,
that's,
that's fine.
Then I'd also,
that allows me then to be a better
partner and maybe be more helpful if I'm
not internalizing it and making it all
about me and you know,
making it,
making it worse.
And again,
it sounds like a recipe for complacency,
but I like the tennis analogy,
like,
like so with success or with matters of
social injustice where you think,
well I need to,
I need to go out and change that in the
world is then it's like a game of
tennis.
If you go into a game of tennis
thinking,
I must win.
Then what happens when you start to
lose,
you become anxious.
You don't play as well.
You're trying to control something you
can't.
Whereas if you go into that same game
thinking,
I will play to the very best of my
abilities.
That's,
that's on the line of your thoughts and
your actions.
That's something under your control and
you'll play better.
You'll get better results.
That's,
that's,
uh,
that's become a big thing for me.
And when I get stressed about things,
I find that something is really niggling
away and bothering me that thought of
like,
hang on it's face because it's always
fun.
It's always something outside of the
thoughts and actions.
It's always something else and it is
fine.
It's normally just someone else's thing
that is just the way they're
manifesting.
That is annoying.
Maybe it's fine.
It is fine.
It feels like when I was a kid and I
used to wake up on a Saturday morning
and think I had to go to school and then
realized I didn't.
That kind of relief.
I feel as an adult so much with this,
that kind of thing.
No,
no,
it's fine.
Think it's a complacency thing.
You mean the idea is that you're,
you're,
you feared that this attitude would lead
to complacency?
I think it just leads to you picking
your battles.
Battles exactly.
Which is important was your,
your,
your wisely allocating resources,
right?
You're not,
you're not concentrating on some shit
that you're not going to control anyway.
You know,
grabbing some guy you don't even know.
Listen man,
you gotta straighten your fucking life
out.
You're annoying and this is why.
And like,
that guy's not going to listen to you.
It's just an ineffective way to interact
with people.
You're way better off going with this
fucking guy and just keep moving so
myself out sort myself out.
And your reaction to him is the only
thing that you could really control.
Certainly can't control him,
but you can control your reaction to
them and there's some,
there's a certain amount of pride in
just being able to like whatever and
just to a person or a thing or person's
behavior that you might have been
furious about just a few years ago or
you know,
or deeply irritated by where it would
cling with you for days you'd be in your
car or thinking about it like.
But the ability to just let that go or
to even enjoy it,
enjoy it,
it's good stuck advice which has come
back now.
It's such a,
I think through CBT seemed to be the way
that CBT,
cbt,
not a cock and bull torture the other
one,
cognitive behavioral therapy that may
for all I know,
both disciplines.
Um,
but yeah,
the cognitive behavioral therapy is the
kind of short form therapy that is
essentially getting into the process of
how an anxiety pattern might happen and
kind of throw a spanner in that works
and make people by being more,
more aware of other possibilities that
behavior kind of undoing it like that as
opposed to the longer form of therapy of
getting into a deeper dialogue with the
self and tracing those things back to
where they come from and so on.
But it is the,
uh,
the founder of,
one of the founders of CBT was,
was,
um,
was explicitly taking it from the
stoics.
There's a very,
it's interesting how that,
how that is coming back and I wonder,
I wonder what it is,
what it is in a culture that's now made
us [inaudible] he was very,
very popular now and there's that sort
of awareness.
It's a reaction against,
against psychoanalysis.
I suppose it's a yearning for shorter,
quicker answers,
which may be taps into this difficulty
in tolerating ambivalence and
complexity.
Maybe a thing as a perfectly effective
therapy for many things,
but it's just interesting how it's
coming.
This stoic audio is cultural cycles of
sort of rediscovering things.
Yeah,
and I think um,
I think that happens with A.
I think it happens with Yoga.
I think it happens with meditation.
They become in vogue and then they sort
of die out for awhile when a new
generation sort of forgets it or doesn't
learn,
and then someone catches onto it 10,
15 years later and then it becomes very
popular again.
Then it's in articles and magazines.
Then people started talking about it and
then yeah,
it's this weird thing that we do with
that knowledge,
you know what I mean?
This is our version of oral history,
we just pass things on and in this sort
of a weird way where,
you know,
we,
we forget that these are tools and then
people start discussing their benefits
and discussing the positive results
they've had with it and then it sort of
builds up.
It's a bit like the atheist argument
thing I was saying,
uh,
as,
as an atheist,
but we hung up on the,
knocking down the things that are
actually just sign posts back to
something that is important,
is vital,
but just very difficult to articulate.
When Nisha said that God is dead,
he meant that the sort of the young,
the unknowable God is now dead because
we were,
now we've established this thing that we
call God,
which is just like the big guy and you
know,
we've,
we've put like a box around it and gone.
It's that.
And in doing so,
we've kind of lost that touch with that
numinous unknowable thing,
which irrespective of what you believe
as like a religious believer,
the represent something that unknowable
force that,
um,
led even as a,
you know,
a hardheaded rationalist is sort of like
there's a.
yeah,
you want to make,
you want to honor that thing because we
never,
we need,
we need to know what it is to step
outside of ourselves.
Yeah,
honor that thing is a great way to put
it.
I think.
I think we have a really strong desire
for some sort of a practice of humility
and,
and true all.
And I would love to be if you could go
back in time and interact with people
where everyone believed in thor and Zeus
and,
and it would probably be absolutely
fascinating to watch how these people
live their lives with this undying faith
in these deities were in control
of all the matters of the unit with no
scientific knowledge at all.
It must be amazing.
And when you think about the fact that
that was,
I mean,
what,
how many thousands of years of human
history people engaged with the universe
like that?
There's other things.
There's only two,
300 years ago.
It was only with the enlightenment that
we dispensed with the humor,
humoral theory of,
of,
um,
of medicine,
you know,
we believed it was,
the fire and flame and all those,
those kind of ethereal substances in the
body that's like that.
Then it was only at that point that
medicine became something that was,
could actually start to fight against
death ward off death to which means
death,
you know,
became the enemy.
And that's what we start to lose.
That kind of respectful,
you know,
death is some sort of companion rather
than just some sort of stranger.
But that,
that's,
that's only,
that's only a couple of hundred years
ago.
Um,
so yeah,
look,
you know,
I'm a huge fan of the enlightenment of
course.
And uh,
as a magician of coals,
you very quickly develop a love of a.
well,
certainly you did that at that skeptical
attitude that magicians have had
forever.
And it's kind of debunking and so on.
That was,
that goes hand in hand debunking the,
you know,
the charlatans and the whole world of
sort of spiritual nonsense.
But,
but that's,
uh,
that's sort of a separate thing.
That's a different,
that's a different thing.
Um,
and uh,
again,
I only can only articulate it at all
because it doesn't,
it doesn't come naturally,
you know,
I,
um,
it's,
we,
we find things that are sort of
compelling because they don't come
naturally do this.
I,
you know,
I don't quite know what that means to
me,
but I think if I,
if I knew too easily what it meant to
me,
it might have lost something in the mix,
you know,
I think that,
I think the relationship to allowing
your life to,
to,
to grow and to transform into whatever
that means has to be surely are
Dr at some level.
Otherwise we'd just pacing up and down
by that window.
Yeah.
Otherwise,
what are we doing?
What are we doing,
Darren?
I don't know.
Know I need lunch.
Well,
uh,
I have to go see if my house was burned
to the ground because I do have it
hasn't burned to the ground.
I hope so too.
Please Marshall's here.
Marshall's here.
We're,
we're all good.
My family was in a hotel.
Um,
but thank you.
Thank you.
So really fun discussion.
I really,
really enjoyed it.
Thank you.
So,
so much sacrifice is available right now
on Netflix.
Now netflix as,
so there's three things on Netflix.
There's sacrifice,
which is this brand new one.
There's the push,
which is the one we were talking about
with the,
um,
the compliance experiment and there's
also the state show miracle,
which was the,
um,
the faith healing thing I was talking
about as well.
And then there's a whole 20 years of
stuff on Youtube.
I don't know if you can even access it
in this country,
but I bet we can.
I bet you can.
Thank you.
Karen Brown please gentlemen.
Great.
MMM.